it says receiving content so we'll see
what's up man
that was crazy yeah you know how many
text messages i got oh yeah people
blowing me up people blowing me up
people were tagging me saying the
podcast isn't live anymore and i'm like
yeah we kind of know
free [ __ ] still in there so right now
it says it is live but i just want okay
i do see us live
it's gonna wait for the people for those
who are in the chat
make sure that you can hear us cat dad
yeah yeah they hit us with the time
frame they hit us with
you on us
so that was that but um yeah man it's
gonna be like i said for those who
just came in right now we're gonna split
this up part one and then part two
that i'm saying so this is part two
we're gonna get into the whole thing
with big cloud as far as gaming and
stuff you know
it it legit bothers me when i like go
scroll past
older episodes and i see a part of what
i want to watch
we did what we were supposed to do the
bill is paid dizzy i paid to build this
buff man
don't come at me my fios is lit so my
internet was fine man everything was
fine with youtube but you know so let's
see what happened
you know they don't they don't like what
we about to say that's what that's what
it is man
well whoa you know what it is uh that
was the playstation fans because
oh my god big cloud was about to go in
on his
playstation
to talk about somebody like like a
playstation dude or
xbox dude that say anything nice about
nintendo or any other console it'd be
like shut them down now
shut them down
so that's what's up as we were doing
previously
we were jumping into the amazing big
cloud his video game system history
he was starting off he was telling us
you know the babysitting thing
and then you know what i'm saying we had
the atari 26 and all that
and then we were going into i believe
the genesis we were right there
before no we were talking about that
he asked me um the sensation the
controller right you know what he jumped
yeah yeah yeah
yeah please sir please elaborate
on when you got your game it's funny you
brought that up too because uh the game
i
the mario game i remember playing on my
64 was mario kart
6 and i and let me tell you something
when i felt like you know you just feel
like something you know
i always knew i liked you
but you know it's funny though you know
you can just feel something was strictly
made for something
when you play you experience it that's
how i felt with mario kart on the 64.
but the problems didn't start coming in
until i started playing other type games
aside from the first part
one in particular i know you guys are
familiar with this mortal kombat
whoa
it was a good game but the thing was
wait remember they didn't have like a
d-pad on the left side it was
like buttons individual buttons so doing
like combos was like
mm-hmm you know it was weird it was in
the bushes
that's why i like nintendo's like
controllers because a lot of times the
controllers
is like like specially made for certain
things that they're
doing and they don't really care like
your game got to fit around what they're
about
and when it's nice to know
that when you touch the mario kart that
you felt that that game was
made around the analog um i felt the
same way
when i played mario 64 when i first ran
into the castle and i ran up that hill
and it just i got goosebumps because
i said this is his whole vision this is
my motto's whole vision
realized and he he made it happen
and he made it there yeah yeah it
started with a controller it was it was
amazing that
that's i just wanted to know that
because i when me you you and middle
level
when you talked we didn't never talk
about
you and 2016
you know what's funny david about that
64 controller the d-pad the way the
buttons
that kind of inspired the hitbox for the
fight sticks you notice that where it's
like buttons
that kind of inspired that in a weird
way and then it's cool it creates how
everything just goes around
but uh the 64 went there played there
you know for a little bit um
none of them done the wrestling game
song
not really wrestling game i remember was
wc there's pure pressure going on right
here
we can't just gloss over one of them
[Applause]
man the wrestling games i don't know
what's going what happened to him it
felt like when chq left the building
the authenticity of the wrestling games
you know hockey right sorry bro do you
remember the
what was smackdown versus raw the first
one yeah yeah fire
back when it came on fire it was just
they had so many good games
but nah it's just
they lost i played rayman on the 64.
um that's what's up so they're from the
64 where did you gotta advance to
ah after the 64. i took that gamble man
i was like you know what
i'm going to try that um ps uh one oh
god
got on that playstation one let me tell
you my first time experiencing metal
gear solid
and that's where all this goes downhill
that's fantastic but you know what the
game that really sold then
i might shock you all when i said the
game that sold me on playstation and
really made me
keep in mind i was younger when i got
into it i was a big fan of platformers
right crash bandicoot yes of course hell
yeah
yeah all right like when you get to that
part with the boaters chasing you and
you gotta
run and jump that whole thing got your
blood pumping back
it was just so great and then when you
play warped and you get to where they
change that they give you that same
scene
but it's polar bear it was like dawg
they went all
out back i missed that and me and my
cousin uh my cousin elijah used to go at
it all the time
he's he got um i remember he got this
game called crash bash
right you're playing that crash bash was
a thing back and it was like his team it
was like it was kind of like an arena
type of crash game where you guys can
compete with each other and
team up and taking duty state it was
cool but we always
go out with that of course i played um
jack and daxter on that
dumb classic stuff god man there's so
many
so many bangers playstation one of
course one of my all-time favorites of
all time which was dyno crisis
oh yeah we missed that game like when i
tell you i played that game
even i remember i played that on pc as
well back in the day because i just
loved it so much guy lost my disc and i
was like you know what
let me let me try it on pc became a pc
gamer quickly
i tried it on pc back in the day it was
funny as hell
love it i love this game and i love that
that horror
feel to it and i was like you know what
damn you know that kind of filled the
love for the resident evil and me and
david talk about this too
and i think he knows where i'm about to
go with this resident evil
yeah he loves my resident evil rest and
evil god
and um it was good where's barry
the master and the master of unlocking
that
okay so question did you ever have a
dream cast or did you play dreamcast
i did play dreamcast i didn't own one
mine did you play cole veronica
oh yes a little bit of that okay yeah
graphic just works
funny you know funny um i know like
people gave uh dreamcast
um i knew gave dreamcast you know a lot
of trash because the controller and the
little um you know the empty little
space in the middle
yeah but that dreamcast has some of the
most insane bangers back in the day like
y'all remember sonic adventure 2 battle
yeah listen that was a that was the
greatest
launch lineup in video games history
yeah yeah
that's the first time fun on nintendo
but nintendo they
they delivered each gen when it came to
those like games those rules
not day one you talking about day one
i walked in the store i think i had 18
titles i went home with that day
you went all out one i always go all out
if they have something that i'm going to
purchase i'm going to purchase it
but you know what's better than that
king what going home with 100 titles
let me let me tell you this let me tell
you this attic it's
it's the fact that when you purchase
your brand new console
right that dreamcast first it looked
amazing i i i still remember
it opening the box but these were all
new games yeah that we didn't get a
chance to touch
that we were going to touch for the
first time
and we went into the store because i
remember we all had a game plan it was
so many games
that we had a game plan who's buying
what
it was too much right yeah and then i
said
you know what while we was there we were
doing that it was certain titles that i
didn't even plan on getting like hydro
thunder
then i said i got to get it i knew i was
getting ready to rumble i knew i was
getting sonic
i knew i was getting virtual fighters i
knew i was getting so caliber
then other titles just started falling
into that blue stinger
and stuff like that just started falling
into the lips
shout out to uh i believe it was uh jay
riddy he in the chat yeah he said the
birth of nfl and nba 2k
just said radio shenmue like they had
some bangers man
you remember you might as well talk
about that
i love this uh thing but um no after uh
playstation one this is where i took
another chance
i didn't i didn't i didn't go to ps2
immediately
i went to xbox wow i went to
og
what attracted you to the og xbox what
made you
set great future wow that game
had me like yo i want to try that out
and another thing that it had it was a
feature that got on my ears because i
wasn't really feeling it until i got it
yesterday
what memory card thing because remember
you didn't need memory cards on xbox yes
you got that hard drive then you got the
internal baby
so i went with uh i went with that got
my jet set radio future day one i got on
my birthday
i was shocked how big the damn box was
oh boxing control controller was
killing children like this
when i was drunk it was like this like
big i was like yo this thing is huge
and when they came out with the more
streamlined was like okay thank god they
thought this through
but um i played so many games on on xbox
i'm talking
marvelous capcom three dead or alive
i played house of the dead wow yes with
the light guns i don't know
no tv
big clown talking right now
i had fun uh dead to rights dead to rule
oh i love you
right was it that was it that was it
back in the day let me let me ask you
this big guy was you doing
the custom soundtrack with you would you
put your music in the hard drive
did you try it oh absolutely i did
whenever i i did
i didn't even catch on to that until
probably like uh
two years afterwards into the cycle not
even though that was a thing you could
do because i was playing games on it and
i was like yo
they just launched the warriors
you can listen to your music and i'm
like stop playing him he's like
so you don't even know you have that
you're right you know you can listen to
the music what yo i used to do that with
this game called
moto gp and um
of all time you know i played when that
was um uh deadly alliance i played that
on
xbox i missed that to this day you know
i was fire
it was great it was great now what jump
uh from that to playstation you guys
remember
gta you couldn't go on xbox you couldn't
get the budokai series which was the
most lit series
back then mm-hmm it still is lit now but
i'm saying it's like it was crazy lit
great
so i was like you know i want to really
try these games because my friends
always have these parties and play them
and i was like you know i want to kind
of
so let me go ahead and get this man i
wouldn't got the ps2
and i was like yeah there's so many
things to choose from
you had spider-man uh ultimate ultimate
spider-man was on there which i loved
yeah
that's probably one of my favorite
depictions of venom in a video game
because you can do the absorb thing
i missed that in there they had the uh
the movie licensed uh
spider-man which i bought that on the og
xbox
on ps2 we had that we had jesus so many
guys
i'm going i'm going back with ps2 man
that's that's golden
was you there day one for the ps2 now i
got that later
okay okay yeah i want to know your
launch experience mm-hmm because you
know that a lot of
a lot of times no no like for any
console like whatever like you know like
a day one
type of anticipation type of thing
because i think
you know with with some of the
conversation we're gonna have later on
yeah
um that that's hugely essential
uh for a lot of gamers you know because
a lot of gamers as i
are in a state right now because i am i
am
i'm frustrated yeah yeah i know
we're all kind of like uh conflicted
going into this [ __ ] that's for sure
because we don't know
anything we don't have the answers but
if you wanna you wanna know my uh
my experience when i first jumped into i
guess xbox right when i got it my
birthday yeah
it was uh excitement mixed with insane
anticipation because you know it's my
big day
yeah and i didn't know i was gonna get
it at all i went to the mall i went to
the mall my mom
she had to work and my aunt literally
took me to the mall
and we went past this shop called eb
games
eevee games games we went in there and
she's like
oh what was that assistant you want i
was like xbox can we get an xbox please
she's like a second uh it's like a
second mom we're like extremely
extremely close
that's how we are you know how it always
been you know
good feeling you were the shopping balls
go go pick that joint out right now
we wouldn't got that i got that damn
game and my damn my imagination just
went with the game you know how it went
like you can
the graffiti all that i was like this is
incredible for what it is
you know it's different and what i love
about games doing that i love when games
take a chance and not necessarily just
copy the same formula
and just have fun with the genre or
art style whatever they want to go for i
love that whatever's off so
did you play jet set on the dreamcast
were you able to play it there and see
it there first so this is the first time
you saw this it's my first time ever
seeing
that it was on xbox i never saw it on
dreamcast
yeah wow real quick loved it
so we got a couple super chats we've got
yeah yeah we got viper xc with the five
dollar super chat shout out to the lords
and panel and bitcloud
we'll have to watch the rest later keep
up the fire
and we got it thank you brother that is
the person that
won that thing and um i think it was
members too
so i'll get you those codes a little bit
later um we got squirrely dan with two
dollar super chat welcome back thought
my sunday was a wash
they tried to stop us but we back then
we have hold on i got jumped give me
call home squirrely fire starter
perfect show guy yeah i know perfect
show going with the two hours to
shout out to the technical difficulties
put that on it there we have crap with
the two dollar super chat
jet jet radio future was so good and
that soundtrack was great yeah dude
yeah yeah
fox
from that man i remember god i remember
ninja gaiden was on expo
there's so many like i'm telling you
there was just so many insane moments
on that damn console and i really
appreciate it that's the thing too i
appreciated gaming for what it was it
wasn't really just like a hobby for me
it was just a
vessel to get away from the drama
because i'm from i'm from philadelphia
i'm not from no
crazy you know what what's that what's
out of philly
north philly stand up
20
my other aunt you know she moved me uh
from there to north carolina
to go to school that's what's up we got
into wrestling went to state and did all
this stuff man
i always had gaming to help me you know
just get through the rougher times you
know we saw i've got a lot of power
but that's not levels no it's just not
just how it was man gaming is like
what i love about gaming is that you
know it can really a lot of people take
gaming and say it can be used as a
vessel for
uh you know like all the craziness we
see out there but really they miss it as
this
uh gaming can be used as like a cure for
a lot of stuff like depression
anxiety you can literally get do so much
with with gaming
and they go what about the violence
here's the thing not everybody plays
those type of games to escape that type
of stuff if you want to get away from
violence do you play violent video games
no you play something that's you and
your friends yeah
joy and that's just what it is and like
mario now if you think mario jumping on
people's heads is too violent i think
you just need to stop tracking stuff
close your eyes and go to sleep
it really is crazy like that's real bro
how far gaming has come
since then you know and somebody told me
games will look like
damn near movies
you lost your mind i didn't think that
would ever happen you know yeah and and
prof profitable like that as far as as
far as the industry now right look where
it's come look how far it's come from
yeah smiler told me you know because
i've been games i was five so
they're 23 years come august 30th i'll
turn you know 28.
but somehow it told me 23 years later
from you know
me being five that i'd be sitting in a
chair talking about my very hobby
speaking of which you know the perfect
transition because i definitely want to
ask you
you know what now made you make that
transition what what
inspired you to say you know what i want
to do content creation i want to do this
youtube thing what was kind of the
inspiration behind that
so i saw so many you know channels on it
i remember i saw
like a lot of good points back in the
day you know back when youtube wasn't
broken
a lot of good opinions i saw a lot of
bad takes not like
yeah this guy is cool but he's not that
you know this guy
like that but then he has this moment so
[Laughter]
one day man i took a i wanted to
actually try it and i tried
one video ironic my first video was on
camera but i deleted that video a long
time
like nah there's no way i can do it and
originally when i first did my youtube
channel i
it was going to be like a cod like
channel like if you go to my channel it
says product reviews
i reviewed this thing called the net
doma router this was for call of duty
and competitive
like just gaming okay
maximizing that that pain i'm doing all
that that was i had it all man i was
ready to roll and then um
it wasn't until linear that my uncle
came up to me and my mom she was like
you know ryan
you have such a good voice you know i'm
trying to see what these guys do
for for podcasts and you know when
people tell me i have a voice for
youtube
i always look at them like are you here
i don't be hearing that like when i say
it and that's honestly that's that's how
i feel
and um people tell me on time you have
this voice for youtube i'm like whoa i
never really thought about it like that
yeah so very radio very radio
i guess i appreciate it but she she told
me like yo
you might as well you might as well go
for that i was like okay whoa
if in order for me to do that i'm gonna
need a few things
damn computer okay keep in mind i'm
playing on ps4 at the time i'm playing
on uh this monitor i'm using right here
that i'm looking at right here this is
the mount that i had
stuck it's sticking with me to this day
it's this fiji
20 free kiwi well it's it's about to get
to the bushes
about to go rates yo it's about to go
right here but
responding though what i love about this
monitor and i never really tell people
this because it's very sentimental to me
my mom's bought me this mod oh that's
what's up i kept this bonded with me for
for so long and uh you know she also
helped me get a pre-built pc when i
wasn't working and i was like sick
and i couldn't really get a job at the
time i went and got that pre-built
man i went and did my first video i
ain't a lot
my first ex i don't know about y'all
because i got nervous before i even oh
hi
i got this [ __ ] you feel like whether
they like it what if they don't like it
what do they do
you know what let me just drop the video
i dropped the video i wake up the next
day i had 20 subs
today i did another one had 30.
35 to 40 and i was like you know this is
really turning into a thing i'm kind of
like
i'm getting the sensation with right i
know people this all the time don't let
my numbers fool you don't let this
equipment that you might see you know in
the future uh deter you from
you know how i go about this uh channel
i literally put more effort in editing
and recording like than i ever did
before and that's really just because i
want to put out the best
me yeah but the message i wanted to put
out there was like
you don't need any of this to grow a
channel you can literally do this with
just your pure passion
and your knowledge and and love for what
you do
i always uh push that message even when
people ask me around i'm
i don't know how to start a channel i'm
like guy just just just do it man
whatever whatever you want to do man
this fortnight
do fortnight but make sure when you play
fortnite you play for the right reasons
you play because you're having fun
like oh i'm gonna make fifty thousand
dollars
i'll be hot yeah don't do it like oh i
got this insane clip and i'm gonna get
130
subscribers off of this one no do that
for what you
truly are like you know play it as the
gamer that you are facts and i promised
you you would be shocked when you see
just that reaction somebody told me they
had hit me and the dm
was like yo that youtube money is crazy
because you buying these statues
so i'll put the piggy back off of that
too
maybe they go home these guys just make
millions on youtube
youtube listen youtube
video might shock you let's see if a
video i got um did uh
10k views right i'd be lucky to get a
hundred dollars for that damn video yeah
you know and keep in mind you take a
percentage of this
[Music]
they take thirty percent know the number
quick
and if you're partnered with someone
else they've taken an additional
additional 15.
so and it was funny you know when the
channel started getting traffic you know
how the scam sites come at you they go
hey
we love to partner you i'm like i would
like to partner with me too not
interested but i just continued to push
forward
in these videos and that ultimately led
to a podcast that i did with a few
people
um rgt you got a voyager
yeah it was before i did a podcast
before with a few uh people bringing in
names okay so after that i disbanded
from that and i was like you know
i don't want to do this type of show i
want to do a show where if we are going
to get hectic it's going to be for the
right reasons but at the same time
i want to have a vibe where we all can
come together talk
and chill you know and it's a little
hard to do that especially when you're
transitioning to that time
when you see this community and how
heavy we all can get over
small stuff right but i i did that i it
took longer than expected you know we
transitioned to cameras later on
but let me tell you i missed some of the
coolest people that i never thought i
would meet i mean i met you guys through
this youtube thing
absolutely and there's like there's a
good side and bad side of youtube you
know it's kind of like
i would say that about hollywood
probably you know that was an olive you
know
there's a good side you meet good people
people who have good intentions and
you know want to see you prosper not the
same thing that you want to see prosper
in fact
and you'll run into those others who act
like they want that you know what i'm
saying
you know you know they quit
they quit they like it's like clockwork
they switch off and they go yeah i don't
like that guy this guy does this i'm
like
yeah yeah okay yeah exactly hit me up
then
but we'll just try to get a word for me
exactly that's how it goes and that's
the beauty of youtube it's like a yin
yang type of when you find that balance
in between and you find the people that
you really
good to work with and you know um who
want to see you prosper but also when
they prosper as well
you know good things happen absolutely i
want to show you
because again you know watching your
journey like i said i i came to you
across your content i believe
initially i came across your content to
boom and then
obviously ada can't put me on to you
before that knows everybody attic's like
my tmz what's going on he knows
everything
so you know but when i came like yo i
really like the style really like one
thing that you do that i really respect
is you pride yourself on factual
information
and doing research and and doing it and
regardless of
platform platforms we know obviously we
love playstation huge fan and stuff like
that but you show respect to other
platforms when they're doing things and
that's one thing i think we need more of
you know it's okay to have a preference
it's okay
to to love something and have a you know
favorite but we can also be respectful
of other people with different opinions
and stuff like that
and that's one thing i really want to
celebrate your brother because your
journey's been really cool
and i see that i've seen the transition
because i remember the profession
but i gotta ask
uncle actually loved that name because
it was like you know that's just ryan
being around a professional as yet
you know i conduct myself professionally
i don't you know i just walk around like
that
refresh like that
when you um when you built the name
around something let's say
even if it's a good name and sketchy and
it has a lot of like uh
bad like negative connotations
i was like you know what let me just let
me redo this like if youtube you can
kind of
start over in a sense yes you know you
really can start over in youtube you
know
a lot of people go this is my year when
the reality is it could be the next year
yep one simple change and you know
a little bit of um a little change with
yourself it goes a long way and i
learned that the the long like really
the hard way you know i just
i talked to a lot of cool people and
that's what i loved about doing like
one-on-one shows i love about that
yeah i love talking about xbox dudes and
people get crazy when i do this i
remember me and uh david
when they were shocked i mean him got a
wrong so
you have someone you have david on here
but i'm like
it's one thing about this i learned i
learned this through
working with playstation and xbox but
it's funny
as many people who say i hate xbox i
learned a lot more from xbox
like for example i learned this valuable
lesson
you know and this lesson and i stuck
with and i was shocked
but it's like you know at the end of the
day you know true change it's not
necessarily a name change it's not a
logo
it's within you once you find that
interchange and you find where you are
things will definitely show itself so
that's why we're getting a lot of xbox
stuff preach it brother dog
you're preaching right now man loving
what you're doing tremendous gaming
history
tremendous story man just just a lot
yeah i learned some stuff today
yeah i learned a lot i learned a lot
actually from right now and um so we're
gonna transition
perfectly because obviously it's the new
the rebirth the big cloud
so being that you got that name
i gotta ask i'm not putting any undue
pressure because i haven't gone
please accused me for leading the
witness
but i got to ask the question that i
asked
all in the realm i need so i'm gonna go
with uh
god awards top game video game god of
war
i gotta go with the metal gear series
absolutely gotta go
with um
wait for it i'm gonna have to stay which
one
i see let's get it um
see what you try to say with your chest
right come on now i know i know two of
them
i know two of them i'm just saying the
one
you say you know two of them yeah
three more franchises i'm waiting i'm
waiting once i was like infamous
definitely is up there wow that's a
focus
oh no now my fingers is falling off
in my knees i'm scared the last two
gotta be the ones i'm thinking
well i liked i liked first light a lot
and i thought second sun was good but um
could have used some more actually i
actually take that back now i can't say
it for a second all right so if
it's off if it's not okay yeah okay i
really think hold on hold on all right
let's go
[Laughter]
we
[Music]
got to go with you know it's funny
because i try this my first platinum
that's the funny thing too
so we got uncharted metal gear and what
was the first one again
god of war got awarded got it we got two
left
two left two left um let's go
these are the most near and dear
franchise this is something that if you
picked up you can't live without you
can't live without
um can't live with it any generation any
platform
any year don't matter when it came out
you know since this game really did um
it really like brought so many good
memories to me especially my uncle
mm-hmm i'd say house of the dead series
one leg okay one of my legs is gone
you got one leg is what in something i
don't know what he wants
another thing i'm everywhere it's so
many great games that's the thing
[Laughter]
man come on big cloud bring it home baby
bring it home
i'm nervous as hell like i'm like i'm
taking a test
[Laughter]
one more game of franchise of all time
this is dear and dear to your heart this
is something man
you either spent hours upon hours just
gave you so much joy whether it be solo
or with friends
this is your heart right here you can't
live without that game name come up
it's reverence come on now one more save
king me
yo the chest said please say tetris i'm
done
shout out to shreem kingdom you guys
shut up
[Music]
no we don't let playstation people
change oh my god don't listen to him
just go ahead man
i'm nervous man come on
all right so the last one that's the
metal gear i said got a war
i said that one so
regulated saying jet set radio um
my knees are on the line you say i can't
even say mortal kombat i can't say
tekken
at all no i can't stay taken cause you
know like
no i played majority of these they're
great games i play majority of these
i just um to say that those are my
all-time
all time it's not yours it's not my
all-time favorites but i love playing
those they were great
jay barry said tekken son so you know
you're supposed to wreck it
i represent dude representatives bart
you remember sitting on a second
what's up come on um
yo squirrely it's so crazy it's really
crazy
i can't think you're blanking right now
i really am blanking bright lights the
pressure
i'm getting stopped in my own
environment here what is going on here
what anything that you like anything
that you like brother desperate freezone
brother this is your choice
bring it home and you said franchise
that's the thing like that
i used to say franchises to make it
easier for people but if it's a specific
game like if it's resident evil 2
go for it like if it's oh yeah
metal gear solids yes gonna go with
spiderman theresa one the one okay
all right now this is starting to shape
up all right i can't say miles because
you already know me and
me and uh david talked about that we
gotta wait what's going on with that
story
yeah and uh the second one so that's
three right there i'm gonna go
with hmm all time
actually i'm gonna shock a lot of people
when i say this one xbox
oh let's go cut that wow
first cuphead ever all right okay so we
have four we
and the last one the last one i had to
throw this out here the last one let's
go
of all time yes let's go
last one don't choke on the face
because i love this game and i really
hope this game gets remaked
and i really do think we're going to get
it very very soon
i'm going to go with um dino crisis
thank you wow
thank god
so the fact that he didn't say resident
evil in any capacity
i lost one leg one leg left out of the
building
if you would have not said dino crisis i
think i wouldn't have finished the show
you know i didn't know i'm going to talk
to you later funny about uh resident
evil king i don't know did you play the
last uh one the remake
no man i got part two i got part two
there
he came to game pass yet brian is out of
the playstation nation now
you know what's funny uh david if you if
if we didn't get the new remake or
resident evil nemesis
yeah i think i instantly would have said
resident evil because you know i didn't
really like the new
i don't know if y'all played uh new ones
they said they didn't like it or
whatever but um i love the fact that
the level of fidelity or where we're at
now
right so for somebody who's never played
the first nemesis
and they played this one like a new
person to
new to the franchise or whatever it will
probably they will walk away
so amazed and transformed from the game
because the game looks absolutely
amazing and it plays fantastic
so i understand where capcom was going
in that direction
uh but you played the original so
yeah comparison right so your comparison
to it is a little skewed
you can't get a different gun which i
thought was going to be a thing you can
at least stop him it will drop a weapon
and you can pick it up and
yeah it didn't bring about which i
thought was interesting it was funny
yeah i remember
because reggie resident two uh remake um
the part with um
what's his name uh the grim what's that
was it the grim reaper it was a hunter
what happened
was that was it was the name of the grim
reaper or the guy i forgot
is that mercenary that scene with the
mercenary you got to escape the house
from this oh you talk about oh you talk
about um chunk
yeah that scene that whole one
playthrough had more
like intense feels than resident evil 3
wasn't it you couldn't like heal him or
something
it was something horrible
um like you could heal but he literally
had like so many damn tools of the trade
he had grenades
yeah he had his own shout out to mr ha
yeah that's that's
his joint all the way live with me
yeah that would be crazy so last
question before we move on we got to get
going
but um yeah so favorite console
of all time favorite console of all time
you're going to have a connection right
now jay barry the playstation nation is
watching
xbox talk i don't know his heart and he
stopped what did you
want to think shout out to eb games
i want this i love this though it's cool
the amount of um
the amount of memories i have for this
particular one and how it this uh
system helped shape me even further
especially going into ph3
and ps4 i gotta go with the goat man
which one playstation two
okay all right okay okay okay ps you
solve or is that acceptable
ps2 ps2 is kind of i mean it's the
answer for a lot of people right like it
is
just because of sheer amount of games
yeah it was dominating
dude at this point like you had
everything you had gta and that was a
big
thing was really getting that like
love you know and it's got into this
global thing where it's like
they're making the the amount of the
damn um
biggest movies of all time which was
avengers yeah
now these let me ask you this because
the chat they're very happy playstation
nations are very pleased with you right
now they're they
got you
no final fantasy and this man's name is
big cloud that that broke my heart
like i didn't get the final fantasy 7
that i thought i was getting so i needed
explanation sir
well actually my avatar is actually from
a character uh from zoids
okay named big cloud as another story
it's called zoids uh
new century zero i think that's yeah one
of the better it's one of the shows i
watched when i was young that's why i
changed the character
this dude this character from my
childhood got you
a few times i'm not really i never
really got into the final fantasy
yeah i would have never brought my knee
on that right i've never heard him talk
about final fantasy so i wasn't even
thinking about it no
no no i lost my knee today you know
that's what you get first stuff
from our conversations you know i was i
was
i was like yeah i i yeah literally
i was sworn in i was like my niece is
safe
when you was going down that rabbit hole
i was like this guy is killing me
i feel like it was just a mistake it was
a mischief return
he thought he was locked to franchises
and then we cleared it up
kind of like like lock but i've never
been i've never been really like
physically hand sweaty nervous
for somebody else's pics and this is the
first time i'm sitting there like are
you serious
like in my head i'm like come on man
stop playing i'm trying to mentally tell
him stuff like
[Music]
yo
i saw you though oh my god it's so much
fun so much fun
we gotta move on back we definitely run
a little bit behind with all the stops
and starts and stuff so we're going to
get into these
polls i'm sorry somebody then we get no
chat
sorry wild gamer with the five dollar
super chat
finally the big cloud is back on iop i'm
grading papers guys let's go
and then the ones after that you read
cog right yeah squirrely dan
and squirrel again again yeah so we're
caught up all right regardless make sure
i ain't missing none too because you
know
something but anyway last week's poll
results are in and the people have
spoken
to the question with the announcement of
spider-man be an exclusive character
to the playstation version of marvel
avengers which of the following answers
most resembles your personal stance
regarding exclusive content
the winner of one of the this is this is
messy oh my goodness
people play christopher heart so uh king
can burst the flames
shout out to blaze big cloud i have the
knee pads for you wow blaze babe
shout out to blaze being messy but the
winner of the poll which is also
messy at 34 shameful lord shameful
if i don't get the content i want it's
automatically anti-consumer
coming in at second at 29 percent was
make exclusive games throw exclusive
content in the bushes
in third place at 21 mad close um was
only if i
only agree if exclusive content is timed
group
and in last place at a close 14 of the
vote was
no issue with exclusive content tied to
any platform
invest in your fan base group shout out
to all the lords
who participated hold on hey coming from
brooklyn again
shout out to jay barry with the follow
super chat vic clown is the homie
but he better play a final fantasy game
asap i'm a professional shin kicker
facts
facts professor
solve your thoughts on that real quick
sir everything i mean you know what i'm
proud of gamers you know why
because we're because you're admitting
that we're selfish we're mad selfish
like gamers care about what they care
about man i'm okay with that
yeah but you know but you know sometimes
you know in in
and trying to be pc about things right
we have conversations and we talk about
both sides of the argument
pc mastery but you know a lot of times
the fact of the matter is
the gamers are selfish gamers are
selfish we want what we want
when we want it where we want it yeah uh
so the fact that that one out
even if it's by 34 and not not a super
big majority but you know
it's like i told you man when after that
uh you know the the conference for
microsoft
i don't care what cognito wants i don't
care what king david wants i don't care
i care what i want yes and they gave me
what i want yes
but apparently it's not just addicts for
by the poll
listen when you go to the store and
you're putting your money down ain't
nobody standing behind you ain't no team
with you
this is you all right so when you're
saving up your money i don't care how
you get it i don't care if you save it
up i don't care if you got your check
i don't care what you do it's you so
when you when you boot it up
you are all alone only when you put on a
headphone and you send a friend request
to a party or something like that
is there a friend with you but other
than that you are by yourself with your
purchase so
you dudes really need to stop acting
like you're on some team you're not
you ain't no team thing no there's no
team so when y'all was trying to get me
to play that fall dudes no i'm not i'm
not
get to where i play it
for what like i did that already i
didn't have to play hip-hop gamer i'm
never doing it again
that's it moving along
we got time we got slow mo with the 2
super chat
has big cloud played a mass effect game
oh
it's not better than the best game of
all time
but you're not curious how you don't
hear because they're like 15 years old
yeah but how you not curious about it
everybody hitting you in the head it's
the greatest game of all time well you
don't get a little bit
starting game pass so i don't blame you
for not trying
time to use my own rationale again
moving on we got to get this going
so look this is king's joy man um
obviously
a lot a lot has uh gone down what's up
screen what's going on a lot is going
down in the industry um
halo effort so can you like me to frame
your family please
yes so the news went down man it went
down shout out to 343
studios and yeah they put the
announcement they said they wanted to
share the important announcement
that they've made the difficult decision
to shift the release to 2021 of halo
infinite to ensure the team has
adequate time to deliver a halo game
experience that meets our vision
and they said the shift release was for
multiple factors i'm not going to get
every specific one but one of them they
did mention
covid and development challenges things
like that they also said they were
disappointed they shared your sentiment
and um they said basically they're going
to lose the extra time to finish the
critical work necessary to deliver the
most ambitious halo game
ever and then we saw we got we got word
from phil dominus he was i believe he
was on an animal crossing show
and um he basically said look like he
knows that the people are bummed about
the game's delay
he also believes it's the right move and
the decision he would not
have been able to make five or ten years
ago spencer says he might
microsoft full bookshop fully supports
the decision even though it would have
been nice to have
series x to have a game at launch and
then at one point they said there was a
rumor
that they were thinking about kind of
putting it in pieces but he said
that uh splitting the game in pieces but
that he said that um they did come to
decision in 24 hours
that that would be not the right
approach so it's big news it's been
rocking the industry lord king you've
had some thoughts some things you want
to
say before king goes you know all that
you read you know the first thing that
came to my mind after i heard that
i was like man craig was lit
the impact of craig it's a little kick
man this is your topic you know i know
you want to kind of
set some things up man what you got to
say what's going on i will first
like to say with all due respect now
everybody knows what somebody says with
all due respect
disrespect is about to come okay
um and then when you say bless your
heart
you know where it's about to go oh hold
on all right so
love bonnie ross i think she's fantastic
um phil you know i love you man phil
dominus maximus spencer soon to be a
realist aurelius will be there
you are you stand on your square and you
said the game won't launch
if it ain't ready we saw it wasn't ready
and true to your work mm-hmm it's in the
bushes
yes bushes it was and um
at what point in time i'm looking with
anticipation yeah it doesn't
anticipate does potential
turn to crap
i i deal with a lot of boxers i deal
with a lot of people who have potential
and they show flashes of it but they
never
achieve the greatness that we think we
see inside of them
and
bungie you can't quantify what bungie
had can't quantify it because they
replicated their own formula
again but destiny and they
showed you they can be great without you
you thought you can replace them with
three four three
you thought a name
you thought talent
will equal greatness and it has been
mediocre one
facts they get right then the next thing
they get
wrong it's like
having a bad juggler
we're juggling with knives right now so
at what point in time do you cut bait
and disband 343 at what point in time do
you just say
they need to take a break split them up
and do something different and work
on getting the halo franchise
into the proper owner's hands
you know you're talking to bungie as you
i don't care what type of bag
you need to back up but
you back that damn bag up something
terrible to make them understand that
we messed up we sorry we sorry
you needed a break you had breaks for
years now let's get back to what you
really do
and let's really do this let's if this
is going to be a service
then let the real owners of the
franchise the real
creators of the franchise work on it
and then let your 343 the little dudes
that had so much potential let them
service it after that
can i ask you a question kick um what is
the most
um egregious part of your flesh
with 343 what what do you what are you
most frustrated with because i i
i sense they're always almost there got
you
like almost is never good enough it's
not anymore
you know why because i'm playing stuff
like the last of us i'm playing stuff
like god of war and this i'm tired of
your excuses i'm tired of you stub your
toe in the middle of the night and you
hit your head on the dresser i'm tired
of
your excuses i'm tired of always covert
or it's this or it's
that or we we switched up the engine i'm
tired
i'm tired i'm in the five years
development support i'm talking
about [ __ ] so much money 1200 employees
here
if you're giving x amount of dollars to
people
i want results i don't care about what
you're trying to do
right i don't really care right so when
you show this and i
swear to god i didn't know about craig i
said
i did
when we went on season game i was
blindsided because it was
not on my timeline shot out the a's with
all the craig beams or season games
then i saw i thought they i thought
somebody was being stupid and stripping
the the the the grunt that was the root
that was at the end
that was talking i thought they stripped
him of all the time i can't contain
himself laughing
and then and then come to find out
nobody did nothing you did this to
yourself
like addict fix your face
this is the thing about that right
because the king was disgusted by that
and i think he was more disgusted by the
fact that they embraced him
like they were like yeah we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna be in on the
joke as well
right and that to me that's what killed
me because i'm like yo
y'all like once again it feels like
y'all letting the bully curb stomp you
right and then and it's like
no don't don't do nothing
like it's like this is you just like
this is how i'm gonna take this i'm
gonna hold this out
yo so i equate it to this a grown person
that boo booed on yourself
yeah you stinking they're telling you
you stinking like you stink
and you in on the joke like yeah i stink
yo i'm dead no because
like i said the bully analogy isn't a
playstation it's about how the internet
reacted to it right
and rather be like yo we messed up you
embrace it you laugh
we love craig that's that and the other
you know like when you when somebody
beats you up constantly right
your parents will tell you like you know
what punch them in the face
puts them in the face and that that'll
all stop right and then
and these dudes are not punching nobody
in the face they they're embracing the
bully right they're like right
yeah yeah
homie like so when that happened and
they embraced it
and they embraced it i'm like yo dude
really
we getting a little feedback from the
chat and they said i said king
they respect you but they respectfully
just a few that's most of the boston
chad agrees with you
but sister few are saying you know what
about halo 4 king what about halo okay
i'm gonna tell you this right i'm gonna
tell you this
i'm gonna tell you this all right what
about halo 4 what about halo 5 put them
on the screen do they look better than
halo infinite okay
oh okay all right so let's do it if you
really want to
if you really want to flex your muscles
and you really want to act all crazy and
you want to act like
i'm bugging out i just want to point out
that the best
cases scenario is insane what about the
old games like
they knew games should look better than
they old games
straight up we should have all been like
blown away because i remember a lot of
people were
weren't really impressed by the ps5
showing you know of games
you were expecting more right especially
what microsoft was
uh really was aaron greenbrick and
that's his job obviously he said uh
you know um these gamers are gonna look
and play better on series x and you know
that really bothers you this is like the
eighth time i've heard you right now but
it's
the reality is you know the marketing
since the announcement
of the scarlet the halo infinite has
been
tied to the launch almost exclusively it
was almost said that this is going to
launch with it
from we've been kind of marketing has
kind of knocked that in our head so i do
understand
and an aspect of what i wanted to say
though like to king just
again i got to ask a couple more
questions because chat is shocked
they're like oh my god i can't believe
it
so the thing is like they want to know
so you agree
that the game needed to be delayed do
you think that was the right call no no
no no no
okay phil is real you know what i think
phil
you know what i think happened i really
thought
phil probably you know took his hands
off was like okay
i'm not gonna micromanage you dudes
right
i'm not gonna be on your shoulder um
how's the game progressing how's this
and how's that going right
and i never want to second-guess you
know
the man in charge no doubt but you got
to check on your kids man
like you got to look in there and make
sure they're not playing with the the
sockets and electrocuting themselves
and doing stuff they're not supposed to
be doing because
i'm gonna tell you right now looking for
life
i'll give you a i give you a story talk
to me i let my son
my son is four years old he's in the
room he's playing with his toys and
stuff like that he's watching blues
clues
right 20 minutes i left him alone
actually yeah yeah 20 minutes i left him
alone he's watching blues because i hear
him in there
i'm playing the game this is when i
notice it can never
happen again talk to me i go in the room
he has booboo all over his tv screen
oh man and you know why you know why
that happened to the king and he had to
wipe down
all the booboo and do that because i
left them unchecked
i did not go in there and check the
situation
you left halo infinite unchecked
you got booboo all over your screen
you got to clean it up yeah you know so
at this point in time
there's nobody to blame but the boss i
feel that that's all right so it's
something let's
let's just say i never thought i'd say
kick say that this is real coming from
cake
let's just say this right
you knew you have one shot
right yeah other one shot
they're gonna see it for the first time
you flubbed it bro i feel that i feel
that i feel that
last point because delilah's a little
hurt so um she
said everybody know i love dude i don't
play with you you know you rock we know
we rock now
the um she said is it um delaying the
game
consider checking on the kids so to
speak
how do you internalize that you could
have did this all right check this out
check check out how how if you if you
did your check first before you put the
demo trail out right
mm-hmm you wouldn't have that whole
you could have did the whole scene
leading up to it
the whole armor doing all that goofy
stuff yep
all of them in a ship and when they was
about to launch out to the ship
coming soon when you saw
what you had you cut the feed
right there we will be showing more at a
later date oh
it is delayed that way craig never show
up
never the issue the issue is
that phil knowlingly because there's no
way phil didn't see that there's no way
you didn't that's what i'm
feeling knowingly let that demo go out
there for the masses to see
and that was the real first gameplay
we've ever seen of this game
and it's just like at the end of the day
i get it it's like it's like i was
saying
over and over again like they had to
show something but if you show me that
i'm sending that back show something
else and that's what makes me think that
they showed that game
knowing full well that they were going
to delay it okay and that i don't think
that's crazy though
i think they're not telling you this but
but this is the thing right if you
believe that that's not the case right
then that means that they put that demo
out
and then testing the waters so if if the
response to it wasn't as negative as it
was right right
then you're almost the same you're
almost telling me then they were going
to release that game oh they definitely
were going to release
it it was almost a surprise
that game was about to be a sacrifice
what does that say
about them no like i get that and i
completely 100
agree with you you remember me saying
the game needs to be delayed but i don't
think they'll do that
the game definitely needed to be delayed
but since craig was so
lit they had no choice but to delight i
just want to say one thing
okay i want shout out to john lennon
um yes shout out shout out shout out
that on iop
shout out to you i respect your opinion
i respect everything that you said
you said the most profound thing this is
the reason why i really don't watch a
lot of people's shows and stuff like
that but i've always watched digital
foundry
because i just want to see the behind
the stuff for stuff that i don't do yeah
he said cut ties with the xbox um x
mm-hmm i'm with him um yeah
cut it there's a there's there's a ruler
i don't know i don't know if they're
gonna be able to let me just click let
me play something i'm gonna give it
right to you i'm sorry
um delilah first of all shout out to
lala that's my homegirl i'm just playing
when i say disappointed i am being silly
she did not say that
i just respect her opinions so much so
when she asks a question
i'm just going to reiterate so please do
not attack her it's not that serious
this is my oh you better leave her alone
anyway grab back on point get back on
point i'm sorry
it's like look like i for like to me
the only way that you would not be okay
with this sorry kid smith
is if you value the series x more than
you value the halo brand
and to me i value the halo brand
way more than i'll ever value any any
plastic
and the halo brand is one of the the the
games
it's definitely one of the most
important games in gaming history
and it's one of the most important games
that got me into the gaming
scene so yeah when i saw that i was like
look i like the gameplay i hope
it's fixed by the time it comes out but
i prefer
it be delayed but to me i felt like
they valued it being a launch child of
the more they valued it being a game
and i think that once the stuff happened
with with craig
they're like look like we've already
took a hit this brand's already took a
hit
we cannot have this come out and take
even a bigger hit
right so it's just like we it's like
it's like i said
the delay is good because sure it's
going to hurt the xbox series x in terms
of launch title
but i don't if this delay is what they
need to make this what they wanted it to
be
this delay will help the series x in
general
it just won't help it at the beginning
i'd rather have
a game come out six months to a year
after it was supposed to come out
and be a bigger hit then it comes out at
the beginning and people just drop it
after two weeks
no doubt yeah let's get let's get a big
cloud in because um
bitcoin i respect your opinion i've been
watching your videos you know one thing
i
really respect that you you said prior
to all this was like yo
he's like i'm a playstation fan but he's
like i
am rooting for xbox to be competitive
this generation you stood on your square
consistently
you were like i'm looking forward to the
showcase we've seen the showcase
obviously mixed reviews as far as the
rest stuff i mean most people like the
rest stuff but
halo infinite definitely came out with
the you know the banana and the table
people
all right you know what i'm saying yeah
so now that you you know the
announcement has gone down
you've got more time to process it where
are you at with this thing
yeah so like you brought up again on
twitter i posted it out before the show
went live because at the end of the day
like i know a lot of people get into the
console war but let's keep it real
all as gamers we need microsoft facts
your playstation
we need nintendo the last thing you want
is is showing to have a monopoly
right you don't want to because we've
seen how that goes
you know the 360 brought the best years
in playstation
when it came to their first the ps2 was
so lit they thought they'd get away
with a 600 console in like 10 years
they're like oh you're gonna buy it
anyway we're number one at the time and
then that's what
[Laughter]
it was funny because they have walkmans
they had all that
a good way that's everything yeah so you
know we need we need competition
but after seeing that you know
immediately you know what i thought of
when i when i first saw it because it's
funny
my reaction to it is on the channel my
live reaction like it was funny i was
going it was crazy that i said this
because i was okay this trail looks good
you know them putting the suit on them
and
yeah that look good yeah okay this game
is going to blow me away that trail
looks great right
get to the game i'm sitting there going
the first thing i asked the chat and
everybody could vouch for me that's in
here i was like yo guys
is this running on xbox one
it was different for me because i was so
hyped that the gameplay looked like the
way i consider halo
i wasn't even paying attention how the
game looked i mean
yeah people do have a point you know
they definitely need some work
as soon as i saw that my initial
reaction from the trailer to the
gameplay and i'm like okay is this xbox
one and then i saw the pop-in
with the trees and then i saw the pot
and i saw the ship literally go
through the tree i'm like yo what is
what is going on here you know
it's kind of like it's kind of like this
it's kind of like where you go it's like
real life when you go on a job interview
right
what is the most important thing you got
to do first impressions
first impressions get a job
or to make an impression on people when
you say that this is your flagship
title yeah and this world's most
powerful is console
you know what you know what i expect to
see yeah i expect to see something
that's going to let go you know what
damn console gaming has reached another
you know
i expect to not only make you know make
me go you know what damn i might
actually want to buy a serious action
i think again a lot of people give in
paris a lot of trash you know nowadays
but
paris said it very very well at the show
you know he said you know
microsoft did their thing but they did
little to sell you personally on a
series x
and i was you know what i agree with
that perfectly because it's like yeah
do anything with this uh the showcase
and then when you get to the memes
first of all i didn't think the meme was
gonna happen yeah the biggest crazy man
start we're going to talk about the
popping man i i turned away my camera
30 minutes later yeah that damn thing
you know i went to sleep and woke up and
was on the show and i did not know
anything about
it right now
the spiderman is what killed me what he
was everywhere i go i see his face
the beast was crazy
it was everywhere did you through the
gtx on and off
did you guys see kiss smooth's little
pony
so much happened in 24 hours it was
incredible like kiss who officially
became a legend that day
yes this game got slandered
and i was like you know it was it was
funny because i had this conversation it
was an adult conversation what about the
last ones too when people were trying to
spoil it
you know spreading around the leaks i'm
sitting on guys
before that show even went live i won't
record you guys you know on the channel
i was like guys let's just hope i'm
gonna say right now this show
better delivered right like otherwise
the internet i promise y'all right it's
not gonna be kind see
the internet's not gonna be forgiven if
this show does not deliver on everything
big cloud is
i think the show delivered it's just
halo was such a bad
start that no one cared about anything
else after that
well yeah i mean it's true that's true
because you know again it was kind of
like one of those
um it kind of brought back that game
fallout 76 vibes then it just was
incomplete
and you and you have to like you know
you're going to be paying for the
the full experience but it's not i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna
totally dump on the game right right
what i'ma say is this
it was half baked right if you eat
anything that's half cooked
it's not right right it's just not right
right
um so the main feature you know that was
missing
it's it's ray tracing yeah i really
thought that it was running on a um
xbox one x i really said that to me yeah
absolutely in my heart of hearts i think
that's the max
power yeah of an xbox one x i think
that's
you pushing your xbox one x to the to
the brink
so for them to say that they don't have
uh ray tracing
that was mine that was a huge problem
for me yeah that's the key feature yeah
um more than sony ass did anybody
obviously yeah
where is it and you saw popping i saw
popping on grass that was
a couple of feet ahead and i was like
picture later looking yeah like it they
zoomed in and then um
the clouds see the clouds in the
mountains well you have 12 teraflops
it ain't none of that supposed to be
doing that like
brute force wise it should not happen
right so the thing is unless you build
the console around that game around that
engine around the series x right you're
gonna have stuff like that
yeah well i think it was on the xbox one
x and whoever
whoever imagine what that looks like on
my ass
oh boy whoever's idea was whoever i
was severance package talk to you
tomorrow
talk to you tomorrow and i know a good
boss
a good boss is going to take the weight
and he did he went on the next show he
took the weight
he he took the brunt of it but he also
stayed true to his word
if it ain't right it don't [ __ ] because
that
i got to give you that kick because at
the end of the day i i think i had this
conversation
with uh i'm gonna say brad and rand one
of the two
and i was convinced because they had
boxed themselves in a corner
it was gonna be a sacrificial one yeah
like they almost they
so associated the series x launch
with halo infinite that i thought even
if it wasn't ready
that they would be not saying it was the
right decision it was the right decision
delay
but i thought there was no way they'd go
back on that because they they
all the years of of the marketing this
way
let me explain why i thought your view
was right
yeah and this is from the business time
now now this is business hacking let's
go let's go
you have a deal with monster you have a
deal with uh taco bell
you have a deal with a couple of other
people actually
uh going through with halo only right
that's true
that is sure right now you're also
launching your console
so if you're having marketing deals
for a game and all this stuff is printed
up and ready
yes yes okay september is right there
you can smell september
it's right there right that's when the
marketing is going to roll out
right this stuff is tied
yeah to your financials
yeah there's projections
from all these companies all these
businesses that you
told that you would deliver right
and for you to come back and say
nah we're gonna push it to next year you
know you know how much strain
and ties are messed up because of this
and notice
notice no window in 2021
just say that when what time they didn't
say lately
oh well i think i think the reason you
see that is because they don't want to
give a definite name
because they do want to make sure that
we they don't have to delay this game
again
they didn't give you a time when um last
of us two was coming out they didn't
give you a time when
the stream was coming out i just thought
it was interesting that they you know
sometimes sometimes people use
a verbage like you know spring of 2021
or you know
no i think they want that to be
completely blank because if it comes
down to them they have to push it back
to holiday they never said it was coming
out at the beginning
of the year
i am shocked right now because the
entire
realm was waiting for solves opinion on
what happened and they were
based on you you kind of hinted a lot of
stuff about your feelings last
iop song and people were waiting they
were like i want to hear what's up
playstation nation was riding with song
last week so to hear everything kind of
switch right now okay i just want to
know where you're at
we've had what time and you know with
this whole situation
it i mean it's interesting because you
know king and i went when's when the
news came out you know we have our
discourse on our project
and then king and i immediately
disagreed right yeah because
he he first i read and ate popcorn
i was telling people if they could only
see what our ilp
turtle i said sunday is going to be
lit watch out for some i know it was
watch out for king
no and that was the thing i'm
immediately like because because i did
not expect him to ultimately fall closer
to where i
am yeah then because originally it was
like now we're the opposite end of the
spectrum right
we both completely agreed the game
needed to be delayed
always delay a game i don't care what
the circumstances are
always the leg game we're gamers we care
about the games
if the games are not good that's what
bothers us right
delay the game fantastic my my reaction
to it was
though and this is again i don't this is
the way i feel
i you know when you delay the game
less than three weeks after showing it
my feeling was that they had that in
mind already
and then at that point it goes back to
my frustration with
xbox sometimes it's like guys why just
step back for a moment and look and see
how bad is this gonna make us look
right yeah why not intercede before then
just be like we're not showing it and
that's it and it ended the disagreement
i don't know tell me all right tell me
what
positive what positive in terms of in
terms of
no no but tell me what positive in terms
of
how xbox looks how how xbox brand looks
do tell me what positive came out of it
oh there's no positive to it
it's just at the end of the day they
knew that if they had this event
halo had to be there there was no way
halo's not there right in some ways she
performed
i said they should have sold something
different if you come out into this is
my feeling right if you come out and
tell me before the event look guys
we've been working hard no one's dealing
with that no one's doing why not
why not at that point all you have to do
is
you don't have craig you don't have we
don't have anything to look at
and be like they messed up they could
smell that all you would have said
like are you talking about delaying it
before that
i still don't see people accepting that
because it's like it's like this is
this is this game has been this game
has been in development for five years
this game was supposed to be a launch
title
and now you're wanting to push this
game's first game play
even further people would have had less
faith in this
actually because at least when you see
what you saw
people saw at least they're going back
to the old type of game
let me know you won't even even have
that you're like this game
completely messed up i see that i see
that right but
that thing you said right there about
going back to the old type of game play
when you talk about
why i think 343 at this point it's it's
hard for them to
sort of wave their own way i think
ultimately they felt they it's like they
fell under the pressure of trying to
live up to bungie
right and and not never quite getting
there right
but you know defensively let me i gotta
ask all of this
in your defense do let's let's play
devil's advocate because we going hard
at 343.
in your in their defense do you think
maybe it's
undue pressure by management to tie the
development of their game
to a launch like any time yeah yeah any
time you you
know
i get that he's right it's five years
right
and this is another thing that we added
put this in our chat and we never
discussed it we never elaborated on it
after the whole craig incident right
there on there was a reddit thread
that came up with a bunch of people's
exit interviews yeah from three four
three right
and i didn't know if it was true or not
whatever but the general consensus after
reading a lot of those exit interviews
is
fantastic people overall fantastic place
to work
but in terms of workflow and getting
things done it is horrendous
absolutely horrendous like there was no
in between it was great people
the way we work sucks right the way we
work is not conducive to
to getting things done right and if you
look at
the development of the master chief
collection obviously the issues they've
had with
with um with infinite and the changing
of the of the the
the engine and all this stuff yes covid
matters right
hope it matters but at the end of the
day like king said it just seems like
there's something interact
at the core wrong about how they're
doing stuff when in five years
in five years you tell me you cannot get
a demo up and running
on the console you're launching in two
and a half months
i'm not excusing it all i'm saying is
again from what we hear we don't we're
not in there
but from what you're saying with the
glass door right we've heard that stuff
you know those exit interview stuff
and then there are rumors right there
are rumors that um
you know because it was tied supposedly
to the ogx box that
you know for actually but even before
that we heard rumors that
with unreal they switched because they
felt they were having problems
then they switched to you know
slipstream they made their own custom
thing
made that set back again i'm not making
excuses i'm just talking about the
rumors that i have heard
you know what i'm saying so if you
combine all those things right
and then they're at a point now where
it's like okay we've got a show and why
is game upgrades just put a good super
chat we probably got to read it
but um you know to to to come to that
build
i don't know who is responsible for
signing off and saying
yes that is satisfactory that's that's
it's phil at the end of the day and
major nelson has said this
when it comes to when we present
something right
and in terms of like how things in the
order the order it's done and how it's
done
and the flow of each presentation last
word is filled right so
i you know and that was kind of where me
and king sort of disagreed about how he
handled this
and then we ultimately we kind of come
to the same place where it's like at the
end of the day
he had to take that l because he's the
boss he's supposed to take the brunt of
that
but at the same time it's like besides
taking the brunt of what happened
my feeling was he needed you're gonna
tell me he was he was blindsided by this
presentation he like you know what i'm
saying
i think they're sovereign just not to
cut you addict
i think microsoft
um is a prisoner of their own vacuum
right and i'm saying in this
innate this nature when you practice
your dance moves in the mirror
you think you think you're the best
point you think you lit you think
right now man nothing can stop you son
and then you get on that dance floor and
dude is like what's
wrong
is that dude in the club doing that
dance that nobody
and it was the halo face and i'm like
okay
i'm like yo yo halo face move is mad
trash
you can't you can't you can't be in the
club doing halo face
they mute it to other people he was
doing the only thing he was doing a
whopping the bus stops
but i say this right i say from now on
if whoever watched that video with you
that's not your friend that's not your
favorite yeah that's kind
of telling you what you would not tell
me what you want to hear from what you
need to hear someone has to be real i
i think that when it comes to exactly
yeah i have two
you know perspectives on this the first
is i do
think that they had to show something
yes but if they weren't going to show
what they showed
i personally feel like they should have
showed some kind of story trailer
and then after the story trailer they
announced it's been delayed okay i think
that would have been better than not
showing up basically
basically like let me know like what
keem said like describe like what the
ship what this yeah with the ship
just show like just show a glimpse of
what the story overall is going to be
like like you know show so atrial
because i still think atriox is dead
that's just me
right but you know show show something
like that then at the end of it says
uh 2021 and then you know obviously they
have to deal with that but it's better
than not showing nothing at all
i mean i could i could i could vibe with
showing the cinematic trailer because if
they show
nothing i'm telling you they would have
gotten yeah
but i'd rather know it's being delayed
before the trailer
to me to me if you know before the
trailer
you're not going to even care about the
trailer like at least
you take the trailer in and then
afterwards you'll get that
not see craig than see craig you know
what if what if what if halo comes out
and it's it's
whatever you think we supposed to be and
craig was the necessary catalyst to
get a lot of exit interviews going you
know to clean up the mess
oh dude oh no grounded he he's being
sloppy
they should have showed lot getting
killed in the trailer that would have
eased
it [ __ ] about the delivery
let me comment on three four three yes
all right
those of you that know i've always been
one of those you know half
glass empty kind of people with three
four three that is over
no more like three four three i always
do that
i i they get that they gotta go they do
bushes
and it's not necessarily they got to go
off out of like being a studio
they need to make something else clearly
they're doing more damage to the halo
brand than they're helping it
and if you look at it from the
perspective of what they've done
throughout the years
hey 343 has never made halo they've let
trends make halo
they've let the community make halo 4.
they try to have a call of duty
multiplayer because that was a trend
going on right now
that blocked halo 5. i have no idea what
happened there
they the multiplayer was lit the
multiplayer was good but it's just like
i don't maybe they focus so much on the
story i don't know
but okay now let's go with halo infinite
they try to get that destiny money
so it's just like i feel like they
personally
lets trends make their games yeah that's
very good
yeah that's a good point but i think
because the difference between bungie
in 343 is when bungie did something
and no one liked it bungie's like tough
[ __ ]
they don't they don't care bungie does
not care but look at all the stuff they
do at destiny all the time that no one
likes
that they have not changed anything like
that
bungie will literally have a thousand
people behind them say
yo those shotguns i ain't go work man
you better not do that they do it and
they like
we were wrong but you know we had we had
to try it for ourselves
right like you know at the end of the
day i think three four three
i think they're a fantastic studio it's
just at the end of the day
they're they are making someone else's
game they're not making that it's a
halo and that's what bothered me about
the way it looked i'm like
it felt it felt like they built they
sort of
bent to pressure because i'm like all
right with all the issues that people
have with four and five right whether
the single player multiplayer on each
game whatever the case may be
i don't think anybody really was beefing
about the way they look the most
beef that i heard about the the look is
that the like the the metal designs were
very busy right and turned
they weren't simple they were busy but
beyond that they look hot like i didn't
so when i come out and i see this video
he's like he wants you to feel like you
felt when you played
combat evolved no i played combat
evolved 20 years ago
and then you look at it you look at it
you look at it from the standpoint that
you know i do think the
uh spartan movement that they put in
halo 5 i think that was that was 343
right and then instead of holding to
their guns what did they do
we're going to take that out because the
community attacked us uh guess what
people didn't like law instead of
holding to their guns
and completing the vision that we could
have made since by the end of it
right then what would they do we're
going to cut lock out of the whole story
master chief back in
we got to fix this like it's like all
right if people needed them so much
the the criticism like they they're
they're not effective with it you know
yeah i remember uncharted one untreated
one wasn't super well received by a lot
of people
and honestly you know
the community the community spoke their
mind and what happened we got uncharted
2 which is considered one of the best
playstation games of all time feedback
you know what i'm saying
it's it's proper uses of feedback and i
don't think they just
they're reacting to it the right way but
big cloud the game
can once the game was half complete and
keep in mind they were going
they're going this destiny-like route
right where they wanted to be like a
service
right if you were going to ship it in
that capacity it's
half big like king would say right it's
half big and you're not gonna and
you expect people to buy into more
content for this
at what point were you going to announce
like yo yeah um
the game's not fully finished you know
raytrace is going to come later like
what
were you going to get that at all i
don't like that because like you're
really just throwing out a half big idea
and like yeah
oh here it is here guys but we'll build
this over time
right right cloud don't like that model
yeah that goes back to my whole
potential versus crap yeah like at what
point in time does potential
gets old and stale you can't keep saying
that this will be great they will
they will be great because you see
greatness in them because you like the
people there you like
they have their their move set
yeah yeah i just not translated the
problem
king that's a good point because
remember how trash the aiming was in
uncharted when it first got
powerful look at it now look at the
problem with 343.
but they fired the aiming dude from the
first one and got somebody else that can
aim better
the problem the problem with 343
is they do not stick to their own guns
and improve on the systems they make
enough time they abandoned it after one
game because they got bad feedback
instead of building on it and making it
a better product going forward
for instance the all the all the spartan
moving stuff they could have down
that a little bit and kept that in the
game but instead they let the community
make the game instead of 343 make the
game
let me say one thing real quick okay
okay i see people in the chat
addict i disagree and that's fine but
once again
how many more games are we gonna give
three four three to keep ruining
i'm sorry we've had four five and six
infinite
well obviously we haven't played
infinite and you guys could say what you
want four's multiplayer was trash
to me it was one of the worst
multiplayers that's ever been enabled
halo 5 story was trash it's one of the
worst stories that's ever been in halo
if we're going to continue giving them
passes they're going to continue to mess
up you should
yeah let me let me jump in bonnie ross
but bonnie ross
listen i honestly think it's time for
change
at the end of the day they make high
quality stuff they just don't make good
game
halo games they make half halo games
they make half of a product that's good
and it's just like give them the
resources let them make their own game
and i bet you they make a great game
then because it's their baby they
they're more passionate about the
five story was fine a lot of the
consensus does not agree with you philly
and i love you bro
but i mean you can love it and that's
fine if you guys love it
but we have to look at the masses it was
not well received the
marketing was was a bait and switch that
you know it wasn't cohesive i remember
going through a level of cinema happened
and i got an achievement for watching
the cinema and they said that was a
level
there was literally a chapter talking
with two people
you can understand that if a person
likes it that's fine
but if it's not well received by the
majority
then it's a problem i'm gonna jump in
because we're going along with this at
the end of the day
painful move but the right move right
i rather save the legacy of halo
right then to shoehorn it just for the
sake of saying we have it at launch
it could be completely wrong they could
come out and be lit but we don't know we
can only go
what they've shown us so what they
showed is they look in that heart
i'm gonna be real though i'm gonna stand
on my square i still liked what i
saw but i'm a combat evolved dude right
not everybody i'm being see but this is
the difference between me and i'm not
trying to point out my brother philly
eagle but
i'm just trying to make a point in the
sense that i
know that that's for me because i'm
combat evolved and i got those feels
right
but i can let take a step back out of my
personal feeling and say objectively i
can see how someone else
might not like that art style right i
could see how somebody say yo
graphically like what king is saying
four and five look better than that
right i can step out out of my thing now
i thought the grappling hook was fun
i thought the gameplay was fun yeah
craig was spooky no question you know
what i said
but at the end of the day i was still in
i did the excitement of an open world
halo
and then the multiplayer 120 frames i
was still in
where it went left for me is when they
go
oh no ray tracing that launch and i'm
like wait
that's the main feature you've been
throwing at sony like that's the main
thread
facts outside of ssd velocity
architecture all these amazing features
that we've been beating in the head from
marketing
for months about what this console can
do now you're telling me your flagship
game which you also said
prior which showcased the fidelity of
this console
is not available at launch that's a pro
that's a red flag to me
why is that not ready you know what i'm
saying now as far as you know
the other thing we got to be real like
the the the blow
what hurts them is now there's no
differentiator software wise for the
series
x at launch y'all know how i feel about
spider-man miles morales i'm not gonna
revisit it
but at the end of the day it is a
quality
title that is available for the
playstation
having a 25 part of the game it's better
than that
relax we're not going to do that because
that's going to be two hours
like this especially when you count the
mc david already knows
you count mcu impacts oh
oh absolutely yeah that character i'll
be right back
impact you know he tells himself he
doesn't even need right application
that's the funny thing i agree
so my thing is initially right when halo
infinite was thought to be at launch
it's like okay you've got these two
consoles you know
the hardcore are going to buy each side
the sony hardcore is buying playstation
5
infinite i mean xbox guys are gonna buy
series x regardless that that's gonna
think
i'm worried about winning the game i'm
looking at what solves talking about
and how i look at it is i'm talking
about the guy that was on the fence
who's not sure right or the guy that may
have
was a 360 dude right and then he went
over to ps4
so now you're curious like you you keep
tabs on xbox let me see what's going on
now you go into the store right and you
look at these launch lineups
and there's no infinite now right so the
differentiator now is it's a little
larger
that that that's where the miles morales
deal definitely i mean really has more
impact so that's where the impact you
know it's really going to hurt though
and i want to transition because i know
we're going on long but this is to my my
other point right
let's get into the next topic because
i'm just a transition right here which
is
we're hearing the rumblings big cloud
right you're one of the first to put the
videos out
yo playstation 5. they're black they're
going up to every major third party
somebody's going to make their party
they're looking to lock exclusives
they're looking to lock up content right
one thing that we
we kind of assume the series x would do
which is
if they're the brute force power thing
when it comes to the multi-platz
i think they were kind of relying what
they did with the xbox one x which is
they do the comparison and digital
foundry says okay
the resolution of 4k you don't mean just
a little bit better multiplayer but one
thing that i feel is genius that sony's
doing
is they said okay we're gonna buy up
games that
were either conventionally multiplied
or if they're still multiplied guess
what marvel avengers
we got this spider-man exclusive that
you character that you can't play on
yours and exclusive
to us right so now they're playing dirty
and i think it's a great strategy i it's
not even dirty that's aggressive right
it's not about jim said you know i'll
let the games do the talking
right that's what he did he said i'll
let the games do the talking right
because he can't talk he's not personal
when you're not personable you just shut
up and show stuff
check it out because it's funny uh boom
just
tagged me in a tweet uh insomnia games
yes
just tease resistance again yes we're
hearing rumblings
we're hearing it's like crazy i think
somebody follows me like
from that team watch the videos but they
literally
right but i'm telling you they they're
setting up for something big they got
resistance where people are talking
about
your workings of silent hills being made
for playstation five
castlevania is possibly going to come
back for ps5
the list
don't
and jump around and do all this goofy
stuff all we
like and you know i do know that i know
i know you know that because it came
down the word came down the ball
came down you saw that but you saw
a picture and you lit like
he showed [ __ ] my dude
let's also preface it with this we heard
about fake
4k and we know that they don't do real
ray tracing
oh my god oh no
because you know what no one else should
stand up for us
shout out to tcl nations
we got midway monster with the five
dollar super chat the masses listening
to king
that was the best buy and someone
returned their tcl
preach the message have a great show
respect from big cloud
no no no no thank you and we have hold
on
a lot yes
yeah brad was in there we missed a lot
ridiculous
good quality control means no
i came here for the halo slander and you
deliver i love halo but yeah halo 4
story good
multiplayer 9 halo 5 single player man
multiplayer on fire
this is 343's last dance
i agree good girl all right so now we
caught up so look basically i'm afraid
we're we're not caught up i'm sorry
give me a second because i got jumped
crazy yeah attic help out with the super
chat sir oh yeah he's beautiful he's
talking
yeah all right i know i know i missed
something
i got we got wilbo gaggins
i don't like saying that name
five years at least 500 million in one
of the biggest studios in the world
backed by one of the biggest companies
in the world
colvin is no excuse harsh but true okay
yes i am that's true okay then we have
gamers play with the 2 super chat halo
is better off without 343 studios wow
the consensus is kind of yeah they give
us so many chances i mean yeah
yeah it makes sense then we got one bad
mother with the five dollar super chat
don't overlook all the leads change from
halo 5
long goal left last year these leads
added had to captain titanic after the
iceberg
we have jd gamer with the 5 super chat
to me it's not
why is ray tracing not ready yet at
launch it's why would you even think to
launch any game let alone your flagship
game without it
that is true yeah and we have elemento
pio with the 5
super chat 343 needs to drop xbox one
support for halo which is something
which is something that people have been
speculating and making 100
series x at least make the multiplayer
xbox one out of black ops well yeah i'm
interested to see if they actually do
that continue
then we have michael aka fine this with
the five dollar super chat
i feel halo is taking all the shine away
from the good games that are coming to
xbox
but there are plenty of great games that
that that were shown in joy lords that
is
true um it just feels like you know when
it comes to infinite that's what people
are mostly looking forward to everything
else in game pass is coming fantastic
all right
um fight fighter xt with the five dollar
super chat not having halo leaves xbox
without that recognized figure to grab
you at launch there we go
spiderman morons gives playstation 5
that character every one of them
all right so we're caught up i'm sure
that i missed something oh no okay um we
got brad
uh with two dollar super chat lords does
uh halo need to be revamped
i don't think so brad i think uh the
direction that they're going in
is going to be the model that's for game
pass but it's just
it has to be a series x uh
exclusive i mean i'm sorry it's very
nice that you want to bring these dudes
along
just like uh sovereign just said yeah do
the multiplayer for
everybody else let that multiplayer rock
but um
that main game if it's going to be your
showpiece if it's going to be your
diamond girl
she has to look flawless and i'm sorry
it just didn't look flawless jd gamer
said we missed a couple from him so
mr um
we can't be missing y'all
yeah we missed a couple too yeah yeah we
got to get those um
yeah you guys kill me shout out to
michael aka
uh bestie find us he's for the five he
says i feel halo is taking all the
sheets you guys not hear me
from here we got that one uh a big club
you don't you got viper as well
yeah we got viper as well okay so we're
saying they're saying um
i'm bringing up the screen now yeah all
right okay so uh
okay oh yeah super chats haven't been uh
that screen hasn't been working for me
okay see if one of you guys can go on to
it
no doubt we can't hear you at it shout
out to you
you can't hear me no he's messing with
you he said he said i dropped two
dollars because i want that tcl budget
haters
just don't hype up 120 frames a second
so i guess oh
no king is still going to shut up the
system
if you can eventually find it just let
me know because we got to get through it
it pushed me already so i don't have
that i gotta i gotta get to that super
chat page uh
it won't let me launch it so youtube
yeah youtube's bugging out as far as the
super chat is going to read them as they
pop up as they pop up here sorry about
that guys we will get that while
gaming jd we will get you man sorry
about that but look i just want to give
it the big cloud real quick again
what we're talking about with the the
ps5 potential exclusive
one just put put what you said right
there and we would read it right from
right there
at me or solve about what you said
and we'll read it again i'm sorry you
can even make it
longer for this time because of the
messed up like yeah it's all good yeah
youtube do it i'm doing it lord it's
dirty
and we'll do it yeah absolutely just add
them directly so yeah man so like i said
one and there's a big big
big room and i saw your video sir if uh
take two game and yeah yeah
so let's talk about it man what you
think about sony's approach
going around in the community i've been
hearing this um that
uh sony's looking to lock down
time exclusivity for gta and it's like a
700 million dollar deal
mm-hmm something like that now when i've
sold this
i hope so i hope they spend 700 million
dollars to lock down
a grant therefore i hope they break the
bank
to go do that because money
from other stuff so go pray 700
you fools to do that knock yourself out
if you think that's going to make you
win anything how about take that 700
million and go fix
playstation now oh my god
700 million seven listen i want y'all
playstation dudes
to really sign a petition on this think
about this
if they've got 700 million
to throw at get a grant
can um take that 700 million and
fix what's wrong how about fix your
servers how about
fix how about fix your infrastructure so
that you're able to launch with
how about fix the playstation 4 hold up
hold on
let me interrupt you i got i got it to
pop up let me read these
before oh yeah yeah we got to get that
sorry i'm going to read back
all the way from viper um yeah
so i don't know if we'll just break from
the white
marine gamers are too specifically that
we missed okay i'll just read from where
i see wise gamer
okay okay so let me read the one where
it says two okay
why is gamer with the five dollar script
right here's a scary thought they
probably had multiple builds that they
were running to be shown
and the build was perceived to be the
best one so he's saying that that was
probably the best one
oh yeah yeah got another five dollars to
protract from jd uh from uh the wise gay
the wise old gamer phil thinks he's
killing it with the electric slide like
a lot that was a funny analogy
we got a two dollar super chat from brat
king said phil was doing the carton
we got a five we got a uh attend super
chat
from wilbo gaggins i probably butchered
that one
five years at least 500 million of one
of the biggest studios in the world
backed by one of the biggest companies
in the world
covet is no excuse harvest but the truth
okay so that i think we're caught up
there because i read that one i'm just
reading all of them there's only like
five more left
okay uh we got five dollars a two dollar
super chat from gamer play
halo is better off without three four
three industries okay
we got a five dollar super chat for one
bad mother
don't look that all the lead change from
halo 5
longo last year uh these leads had to
capture gigantic after the iceberg i'm
reading them all i got a 5
super chat from jd gamer to me it's not
why is ray tracing not
ready at launch it's why would you even
think to launch
any game let alone your flagship without
it got a point there facts
we got to fight out of this retreat
elemental p.o man you guys
let me read before you keep pulling them
up every time they super chat it pushes
them
all up uh uh we got to find out shipping
from elementor po
343 needs to drop xbox one support for
halo infinite and make it 100
xbox series x at least with the uh
make the multiplayer xbox one yeah with
black ops i don't know what he meant by
that
yeah i guess he was talking about how
black ops was at the beginning of this
generation
all right so we're almost caught up we
got a five dollar super chat from
michael aka
shine away from the good games that are
coming to the xbox but there are plenty
of games that have to be shown
enjoy lords definitely appreciate uh we
got a five dollar shrimp shopping for
viper
xt not having halo leaves xbox without
the recognition figure to grab you at
launch spider-man
miles morale gives ps5 that character
everyone knows yes everyone knows that
and everyone's already played that game
it's called the ps4 being messy
super restored hades i do understand a
lot of people's frustration with the
delay of halo
reasons for it can uh only speculate
being impacted by the pandemic and
losing two family members i see things a
lot differently
definitely uh hate to hear that uh
restored that you lost too sorry
sorry about that brother mm-hmm we're
calling caught up okay cool
back to big cloud you were finishing
your thought with the exclusives and
what they were doing
yeah they was looking to get time
exclusivity for gta
and um again we don't even know when
this game is going to come out that's
the funny thing before we get it because
they literally just announced that gta 5
is coming to playstation 5 so it's like
yeah that's probably gonna be later on
down the road i don't know what they're
doing with gta 5
at this point and i'm not even sure if
your character transfers over to ps4 to
five
it probably won't do that they they want
you to start over they ain't trying to
give you half the
half after stuff
and
shout out to uh jd gamer okay we'll get
it right look i'm gonna get um
attitude your thoughts on the whole
playstation uh approach with the
exclusives
um with playstation yeah just the whole
i mean clearly they're killing it man
they they have a
grain on the thing is is when you have
this much
of a install base right now going to the
next gen
that they can go to there and ask for
the very minimum and get everything
right
because they know that there's a good
chance though
like what are they killing what were
rumors
what are they killing like acting like
something was officially talked about
oh because they put a a a little
spider-man skin
uh on a crappy marvel game that's your
character
your character server full skill
oh they got an exclusive so if you got
exclusive booboo
is that it does it make it hot bubble
you don't know
before we talk about anything being boo
boo i hear jd gamer said that
then i didn't catch one of this let me
just read it real quick okay we got a
five dollar super chat from jd gamer
well that halo you don't get so kong
kyo zone resistance battlefield or call
of duty on console
halo did that for you so you get halo
right no matter what
okay look jd gamer i can't see the one
before that so just put it in there and
tag me
no doubt a king you don't agree with
these rumors
i don't agree with none of them because
they're rumors i can sit there i can
make a rumor today
right now listen i mean you make rumors
all the time
microsoft just brought wb games
you know what else rumor he likes to say
the gameplay
cyberpunk day one and
i said gameplay the x see this is where
your brain don't function right
it's not really my brain this is the
diversion i'm going to divert
this right listen got to use humor
because you know i'm right
with the x that day you can go to the
store and buy it
but you pick it up and you put on your
game pass
cyberpunk will be there there's no
there's no insiders
there's there's no me saying yo
somebody's preventing my idiot
a text message nobody sent me an email
nobody
called me it's my opinion it's what i'm
believing to be facts
i'm gonna say about myself and when it
happens
i want all you to bow down
you want the [ __ ] no let me get let me
get something we got to move hold up can
we go along with this
soft uh what do you think about this
approach man i mean he's
like i said last week it's ruthless it's
lifted but like
i mean this is it's all fair man and
again like
the thinking is that they're really
going hard on this because two reasons
right
xbox is looking the other way they're
not even really trying to do
what they're trying to do in the same
realm and two it probably means that
their first party stuff
isn't 100 ready even maybe a year and a
half maybe two years down the line right
they're already
to speculation that that horizon is next
holiday
um in between that we don't know when
demon souls is coming right right so
true it's just one of those things is
like well if we we don't have we don't
want the same thing to happen that
happened at the start of the ps4
generation where it's like you're
playing wrestle gun
and and and after that there's a long
wait until we get to infamous second son
right so it's it's
it's bold it's bold and it like king
said it's
it's a gamble because some maybe some of
this exclusivity isn't as big as you
think it is right if you
pay for a game that you think is going
to hit really hard and it doesn't happen
then you spend the whole
money to get it for no reason right um
but they showed in the ps4 generation
with things like you know
a one-year exclusivity on near automata
um the one-year exclusivity on final
fantasy
these sorts of things matter so that's
going to carry over
in the ps5 um
so let me ask you a question right did
it really matter when i started playing
it in game pass
didn't name my automata did it really
matter yeah
ultimately no right but the thing is
they're what playstation does and what
what they've always done is like they're
good at that
that moment that zeitgeist in the moment
right and
you see if the automata had come and
gone and people hadn't talked about it
hadn't been talking about it oh god the
game of the year oh my god there's
multiple endings all that stuff
it might have just come and gone and not
mattered right right
same thing like with neo neo was great
but neil
um it never had that traction of like a
second road them had that traction of an
actual
souls game so as good as it was
you know it it didn't move that needle
that much right right right
but this is stuff they've been doing all
along yeah so the the assumption now is
that they're going to do it with bigger
games bigger games the third party games
that everybody knows everybody
used to to preface that you said it's
consumption
we all know what happens when you're
soon
so let's take this a little bit further
let's go around the realm and give a
percentage on what you think this rumor
being true
i want to start with big cloud what what
what percentage you think this is going
to be true
the amount of insiders that we run into
so many i just give it i give it like i
go thirty percent okay
no doubt yeah i probably have probably
about thirty forty like really because
you're like
i think they're gonna do something i
don't know if it's gonna be 30 percent
like gta is a big title i'll give it
seconds yeah i said to in the video i'm
like that doesn't
seem feasible because you know you got
to think about if i'm paying
700 million right you know i'm saying
how is that going to translate me
getting that back
over time over time right here online
more likely it's not going to be ready
into another year that's a good point
right that's a good place
yeah i think if they if they do this
it's not to get that money back
it's to stand out i mean
they see this as an investment not like
an investment for a return but to me i
would agree with king in the sense that
if the investment if the rumors are true
and the investment is
some 30 days that's a waste of money as
far as i'm concerned yeah well 30.
for 700 million that was the
that's the dumbest thing i've ever seen
because i'm like you better lock that in
for a year for paying all that money
that's why i said get
them sorry
we got jd gamer which we're not gonna
miss this time ten dollar super chat i
have to give credit where credit is due
sony is better at marketing and they
have been using the art of war since the
beginning
while microsoft has been dancing cut out
the dancing
microsoft hey playstations
has gotten those movie like um trailers
i know it's like for like the marketing
they they really have stepped it up
absolutely incognito when we first saw
it all the characters on the screen the
dude was walking down the battlefield oh
yeah and the people
they really did go all out me and
cognito was talking it who he was like
you know what's funny
the fact that sony's marketing team was
so
good their pr team had to do very little
this [ __ ]
and now when you catch up to now it's
like
it's not like their marketing team's not
as good as it was it's just right now
you know we they haven't really ramped
up yet that their pr
team has to say something it's like a
deer with their head with their heads in
their life
they're just like i don't i don't i
don't know what to say like they sit
there looking at someone like come help
me
[ __ ] guy with the five dollar super chat
the king is the voice of reason
ain't nobody checking for miles norales
he's no more spider-man
i don't think that's what king's saying
yeah but he's a miles fan he's just not
oh no no instead it's coming out i love
it let's
trust on everything um if if
if miles morales doesn't launch with a
playstation 5.
i probably don't even pick up
playstation that day and that
this is crazy for me to even think in
that way because there's
nothing and let me tell you let me tell
you there's
absolutely nothing on that console
that will make me play anything because
i saw your show and
it was garbage so
it was four titles that was there that i
gave the show of four
but because they have two consoles and
remember each console got two points
that made it an eight but okay two coins
oh my god i gave the consoles two points
each
believe i didn't know i don't believe
half the stuff that comes in my gm
points yeah so what two points if you
would have did a separate show by
yourself for with a console then fine
you would have got five points
well who cares anyways what i'm saying
is
that yeah that miles morales means a
hell of a lot to me
yeah man means a hell of a lot to me
right let's
y'all stop you saw a cinematic trailer
right and with some skip to game play
picture
right y'all saw less than you saw
from halo i think what you're saying you
said wait until you see the game play
before you commit
that it's actually going to be available
that screenshot
has reached recently all right
the only thing that's going to get me to
pick that up
to pick up a ps5 at launch is
demonstrable because i really could
i could i couldn't i could not care less
about
about spider-man like at all i'll tell
you this right so we got to find all the
superchat from jd gamer
uh microsoft could end all this noise
easily
by warner brothers and from software let
everyone know that you've got
permanent license in that all contact
that would be that would be the day the
world did it on twitter
i gotta get my balls off this got to be
a big concern
they showed in play file a lot of other
stuff right
and they didn't show any for miles
pitches and they have not and they have
not gave you the big reveal for their
big launch title
right i believe both of these companies
are scrambling for third-party deals
just to hold it off in time to hold it
down yeah
okay because if miles comes out in
january still in that holiday
yeah still tonight what what are you
we're waiting too and at this point in
time that's crucial because a lot again
um mom and pop you know the mom pops
usually pre-order in like layaway
consoles i have a question for king and
bit
like what do you think of horizons
supposed to come out next year and
there's no game play because because
that that's the thing that
like caught me off guard it's your way
yeah
a lot of sony titles get pushed back
anyway so it's a year away and around
that time another game would come out
that would give them some uh
distance and they can just push you back
a little bit further it'd be early 2022
it could be in march 2022 instead of uh
you know
uh the the holiday season of november i
i don't i'm not rushing that game
because that game doesn't really mean as
much as it means other people to me
but i want them to get that game right
so yeah i could see it in 2022
we got push about like a vow is coming
2023
and hellblade 2. right now there's a
wall up so
we're going to get in then i'm going to
get my balls off jonathan b with the
final swim chat the difference is that
we trust insomniac but we don't trust
d43
sadly sony can get away with [ __ ]
without showing full gameplay
and it's not sadly like so like as much
as i hate to say this sony has
shown that their studios could be
dependent on we can't really trust
anything for
343 does until infinite comes out and
i'm sorry people in that chat don't
agree with that statement but you're
just gonna have to do it it is what it
is let me get my journal
here the reason why i brought this topic
up in um
all seriousness was because obviously i
see this in my opinion i kind of see the
strategy
what sony's trying to do i actually
think it's a smart approach right
so my whole thing is this and this leads
back to kind of what king was saying
earlier stuff like that
you know for the xbox community right
right now this was the generation that
was supposed to be promised
they held the fort down knowing that
studios were being bought
we understand that services were coming
with game pass you know
to me this is a critical juncture and
the reason being is because that that's
the
the the aftermath of the of the halo
infinite delay
right yeah you don't have that that
differentiator you don't have that thing
at launch people have to make decisions
so
now that you've got that morale is kind
of low
and i'm on the record y'all know so i'm
like i p peter moore my guy
right and the reason why peter moore was
my guy people say why peter moore right
one we have to admit it was probably
xbox most successful generation
two you know say the reason being is
that
he had a moment of truth moment and if
you're a 360 guy
you remember when those red ring of
deaths was going popping off
right and everybody was trying to act
like oh that was just
antidote or his man that's it and then
it start to catch like wildfire right
and everybody's 360 was red ringing
and i'll never forget i want to shout
ryan mccaffrey i want to shout he had um
the xbox boss is on sean mcgrath uh
seamus blackley peter moore and phil all
in the room
all the xbox generations right and he
asked peter moore
how was that moment and he said look
this was a defining moment because we
had launched a year before
the playstation we had this tremendous
momentum right appears before the ps3
they were rocking and rolling systems
are failing now
you now have to go to your boss and say
yo we gotta eat this
billion dollar million dollar cost if we
want to save this brand if we don't do
he likened it to a tylenol moment
in real life what happened with tylenol
and he said it was the scariest
meeting he ever had he had to walk to
the microsoft execs the big bucks and
say look
bomber he had a b-bomb right and he had
to go in there and say look if we don't
do it and this is peter putting himself
on the line
the reason why i bring this up is to say
this no one
there's a good chance he's leaving their
unemployed exactly
right so no one is saying blaming
phil 100 for the series of events but we
have to admit they were rocking and
rolling at the video game awards right
right they were on the clock cloud nine
hellblade
and you had to tear down washington
austin evans
yeah they gave you the box immediately
right
you know from here on fire we sitting
there looking at playstation like yo
what you doing because
cause you think somebody's gonna come
out this year we thought slums will come
home next year because sony was so
laid back
all i'm saying is these are those and
this is where i'm gonna solve now these
are
moment of truth leadership moments in my
opinion
i'm going to watch between now
and then the launch because at the end
of the day
you've got to build morale in this base
that has been waiting and this is the
generation that's been promised right
this is the
the games were supposed to be coming and
be ready it's not happening right now we
just seen what happened with halo
infinite
you know i like the third party showcase
but at the end of the day i have to
admit
that the gameplay was not shown for a
lot of stuff so that was a stumble right
so we had these little series of
stumbles that have now led us here
this is what i feel that has to be done
this for me
fulfill to get back to being dominance
is one short-term move
realistically whether it's what king is
saying with a third-party game
jumping into game pass whether it be a
cyberpunk i don't know how realistic
that is
we are now hearing rumblings and i can
say it officially
right because i was told this a while
ago but i couldn't say it
but i am hearing rumors and shout out to
reddit because if you don't believe me
go to reddit
that uh there are rumors that they are
in talks with ea in some capacity
i don't know how i don't know the extent
it is
reddit is popping right now all right
i couldn't say it before either because
now i can say it's public information
i ain't snitching my sources but they
are
saying that that you know there's some
type of negotiation whether it be game
pass or some type of
uh move to get i think that would be a
great one because again
if you have a madden a fifa
or whatever in game pass at large no
matter how as a hardcore
you may not care about it but madden
when it's in
what is out there on mpd as far as what
it launches we know what to do
fifa worldwide we know what to do to
have those type of games in a game
passer
again rumor rumor i'm not saying this is
official
just saying these are rumors right okay
so if that's the case
that's a power move in the short term
right you free up you you help the
launch
a little bit right with those with the
game pass you sell services services and
all that
now long term this is what i need kind
of what king is
you got to go up to sacha
and say fam we've got to either whether
it be wb
bungie you've got to give hope to this
base
this base is beaten down there is no
reason for a non-hardcore
person to run into the store and put his
faith
in it without the games being there but
if you show this video
right if you show this hope that they
are doing these things
that's how you get people to say you
know what phil well i'm rocking i'm
standing right here
i can hold the fourth down that's what i
want to say the wb
that's what i'm about that too though um
i know a lot of people pull a lot of
faith into the batman
whole room honestly i don't think they
should even waste your time with that i
think they should just go to
marvel themselves and create their own
love it i would love it but
i don't care who it is big cloud my
thing is if you're going to promote game
pass as
the thing just like netflix you got to
have content
yeah you got to have guys that quality
studios whether rocksteady netherrealm
all these guys all those support studios
whatever you got to do bungie whatever
you got you
now have to have that heart to heart
with sacha
kind of like how my man had the heart to
heart without and say look
and now the good the good thing that's
going for his favor king
is when we saw those fiscals and they
were saying
he still got the green light to go out
and do it
so my thing is i'm watching these are
moment of truth moments
this is where it is and that's all i
want to say they doing netflix you know
i'm saying just buy
whatever you don't get philly i'm with
you bro it mass effect trilogy
remastered look
i'm in all that ea catalog because let's
be real ea play ain't moving out here
orion is moving against um an ea play
it's it's that's that's a misnomer
it's it's actually isn't it like the top
two
uh games of service something like that
right it's it's
it's definitely moving but
and since it went to playstation i i
thought that was a great move i thought
finally playstation
put it there i thought that was really
smart right um
i just feel that yeah madden works whoa
um
fifa reef well fifa words oh fifa
um but i i thought about it the first
time and then somebody
you know talked about it and i was just
like i dismissed dudes um
but when i saw their um third-party
showcase
and madden was there i didn't understand
it
right i'm like why is it here okay cake
not even that
nah i could talk about it because now i
can oh let's get these super chips go
get this one before i forget remember
when xcloud was announced
what game was in xcloud madden exactly
which had no bid
and then here's that had no business to
be there here's the other thing
i was part of that test group they had
their own
streaming service ready to go that at
the time
i was under mta you know yeah so now
that
would be a collaboration with the stream
i i remember playing need for speed on
that it wasn't great but yeah
but they had an infrastructure in place
so to me
if you putting madden on xcloud you're
betting
on another horse instead of your own
for cloud infrastructure continue
kicking yeah the super chats
no no i believe yeah let's get some
chats all right we got all right so well
hold up before
uh you know there's 374 people in here
you guys well let's get let's let's hit
that like button let's try to get that
over 200 before the end of the podcast
you you go i've my voice is gone
jd gamer with the 10 super chat
microsoft should say we lost halo for
launch
walk up to ea take two activision
bethesda sega konami and square enix
and drop off a bag that makes sony choke
big bang take little bang always just do
it
agree what is kind of funny is like
they better hope they never get petty
yeah
we're going to see we caught up again
microsoft should show sony how to money
hat for real
and we have after that we have a midway
monster
with the five dollar super chat uh
i've always felt ea and xbox were cozy
with each other just waiting for an
opportunity to partner up
food for thought ea titles day and date
that would be
insane that's a huge deal
well yeah when you think about when you
think about how ea play
the only the most thing that that's
appealing about ea play is those titles
day and date that's it
because everything else the back catalog
is whatever
let jd gamers chose to use the super
chat we missed
on this statement read this one look
phil
i know you're watching this get iop and
just a few others to make a test group
for these showcases that way we have
more cred we don't we have no more craig
moments
no don't don't use don't use me
don't use me let's catch up so yeah i
think we're caught up
all right cool so let's get it we got
more i just wanted to get that off again
it's what we're hearing these are rumors
let's move on last thing solve just
breeze through this and then we gotta
get existing
yeah god tim tim sweeney being messy
fellas then somebody being mad messy so
epic games uh last week went ahead
and added a direct payment system
to to fortnight on both uh well not
not ios but ios and the uh app store
google play app store
so that players could decide whether
they wanted to pay epic directly
or pay whatever fees uh you would pay to
those platform holders i.e the iowa
store or google play um
knowing full well what would happen so
immediately
obviously this is not part of the rules
you don't you can't do this
almost immediately fortnite was banned
from both the ios store and the google
play store
at which point like i said tim sweeney
being missy messi
comes right back with a with a parody
video
all right of the 1984 um apple video
when they were announcing the macintosh
for the first time and they were
uh at the same time also parodying
george orwell's 1984 which talks about
the
totalitarian uh society fighting against
the man
hashtag free fortnight free fortnight so
they they they play
they make a play on that um where
they're saying basically look
we're fighting against the man right now
i'm done
make the man
um
when they did that after releasing the
video
then they go ahead and they had this all
prepared because they knew they were
deck they then proceeded to sue
both apple and uh and google
for the rights to not they didn't want
damages from them right
all they want is for them to eliminate
what they deem as a monopoly
on these platforms
you know it's crazy like he's a fool
this is what's crazy this was crazy the
fact that epic
epic has this klaus based on one product
it's it isn't even the one that we know
them for from beforehand
it's not the this is not unreal they're
doing the talking
this is a product that at the start of
this generation was a joke
and they now have the clout to move
mountains with fortnite tell what do you
got
this is hilarious to me
so that game is just bad i can't
i can't say that without well do you try
to implement it like with the
battle royale style like no no this is
without
fortnite i think there would be a lot
the the industry would be way different
it's industry like no they're the reason
we got cross progression cross play
i'm convinced that they never would have
came up we would still not have this
like fortnite is the game of the
generation period like this
yeah i hate it but yeah but yeah
i'll give it that i mean it is one the
big fortnight
besides minecraft fortnite's probably
the game that has moved the entire
industry for
more than anything else i hate it but
like just think about it they
first thought they came out the sony be
like yo we want cross play
what's up only
sony cave all right we have stitch with
the 20 super chat
uh i'm dropping this like like king
dropping knowledge cyberpunking games
pass he is not
too far from the truth yeah i mean that
that that's a big truck
that's a big truck you got to drop off
at the very least give them whatever
they need to have that
series x patch it's a ready
assigned sale delivery
so we have eagles fan with the 2007 chat
thunder splinter cell game exclusive to
xbox hell yes
that'd be awesome let's do that then we
got michael aka bit size finest five
dollar super chat
team galaxy fortnite is still in the
galaxy store real talk
um interesting interesting so we go
yeah so what do you guys think of this
man this is hilarious to me
i think that i think that when it comes
to
it uh part of me thinks that ea
that not yeah part of me thinks that
epic is being too too much
but the other part is like you what the
world
i'm like i'm like i i i don't know why
but having multi-billion dollar
corporations came to a video game
company i like that
also another multi-million dollar
question
but but you can't really compare epic
that made one great game that blew the
hell up to multi-billion dollars
no trillion no they're not doing
microsoft microsoft
they didn't want that fortnight smoke
they said all right we'll take our ball
we're going to go home we're not going
to mess with you
oh big cloud what's up man where you at
with this thing man i think doing too
much or
what's up oh like again i never
understood the appeal of the game
at all i never brought in he was free to
play my dog i don't know what y'all
seeing this
like that you have like halo coming out
that's going to be free to play because
they can't compete with them
who know i'm a youtuber they'll see the
setup to go around you play
and i'm like
it's the biggest game this is one of the
biggest games of this gen for sure
absolutely but yeah
i don't like the impact that is
happening
one of the biggest games that is the
biggest game they do it too much
i don't like that call of duty's trying
to copy the format i don't like
everything
i just don't like it i'm like dog yeah
like yeah for once
the original yeah make your own i call
it the bumble rap of video games
everybody's copying it and you know
what's funny
remember remember you know it's not
copying that like do something remember
six months ago i told you guys
don't count fortnite out because
everyone in this thing was like
man warzone done it they've deep thrown
fortnight
i was like now epic has taken
multi-billion-dollar corporations to
court
all right i'm just going to laugh
everybody who's like really hi
y'all i'm missing the whole thing
i'm about to go after you okay all right
tim
sweetie is throwing the meat on the
table oh factual
facts what's the best part about the
meat pause
they have their own store that they
don't pay nobody for yes
yes it's time to deal with one hand
holding the hand and it was waiting till
they got strong enough
yes they were waiting
they was waiting for a moment of
weakness now the moment of weakness
happened
we're marching well said
yes and they said now is the time to
strike when they are
gonna have the videos waiting ready they
have back to back ready
he was on the phone with the lawyers is
the video done can we do this now
then they come out with um a custom
three um xbox one for
fortnight as well it's like a perfect
yeah yes i believe so i believe so oh
okay
all right here's where the messy gets
really messy yes right not only did he
stab
him and say stick him up
pick him up they threw they joined in
their knowing
yes they're about to get canceled right
they know the world
they know when a little kid pick up his
phone yes
fortnight not what the hell why can't i
play it
going on apple
really going on facts now
the world is on fire who knows this
right
and i can this is the part where he can
make them bend the knee i told you
they're going to bend him and he said
you know where the other pressure come
in
financials so now here
where the this is where the monkey
wrench comes flying across the room
we're suing you yo how do you go ahead
and legal suit ready
this is the most premeditated thing i've
ever seen
they knew they violated and they knew
that was gonna happen
and then they had the lawsuit ready to
go you know what's crazy they they know
they losing this
like
he's not going to lose this i don't know
this is where the epic is going to win i
don't know
this is where hmm say like let's see if
epic change the whole industry by doing
this
good i don't know right
that okay so it's out of the google
store it's out of the apple store
the first one out of those two
when back those subscribers right
let's say it's back in the app in a
google store
the note 20 is going to sell like
hotcakes
so all apple dudes don't want to play
fortnite
microsoft wins in that thing too because
oh we have the game pass
game control we're starting to play this
now
once apple loses the fortnight
demographics
and they're deemed as the evil entity
right and they lose the money because
they're going to lose the money as well
they're going to lose in court
they don't want to sit in court that
call argument i would shout out the
whole guy was with hogan rap yesterday
there's some stuff here this is the
second side here that's crazy i'll get
my balls off when you finish
15 is gonna happen they're gonna bend
the knee
fortnite is gonna make them bend the
knee no more thirty percent is gonna be
fifteen percent how they wanna
look here's the deal here's the deal
shout out the whole he's all tremendous
virtue legality on this
that we on brap on saturday with a rant
here's the thing
this all this hashtag free fortnite
these dudes right now is all about that
cut
because they don't want to pay that 30
percent they don't they not trying to
act like this some oh this is some
passionate humanitarian movement
because how dare you take fortnite for
people no you don't want to pay 30
fam that's all this is right then the
second thing where they being slick
is they are trying to break down a
walled garden
so apple makes a product and they say yo
if you want to play
here which is your choice you don't have
to play here
right if you want to put your game here
you gonna pay this 30
and you gonna buy to what we want to do
this is our club
right they try to say nah you got to do
you got to put our games and do what we
want
how we want it in your club so right now
this is
a big deal they talk about sherbet acts
they talk about
this is a attack at the walled garden
and here's the funny part i will give
king this
they are willing to lose short-term
buddy epic
but because every time epics not i mean
fortnite owner in that store that that's
money lost y'all you know
so they they are putting a big risk so
even if they don't ultimately win the
way hulk broke it down is
is most likely going to be a settlement
you're not going to do
no 30 probably they probably maybe they
negotiate the price down or whatever
and then obviously it comes back and
whatever here's the funny thing though
the thing where
microsoft is watching with an eye is
because now this is where
i agree with epic on this part where
they are on where apple is being unfair
especially with microsoft is saying yo
you allowing us in there but then you
saying
oh with games we gotta review each
individual
game before we could put your ex cloud
in so then they like they don't make it
netflix they like yo so why you ain't
reviewing each individual movie
that come in like why are you treating
games you know why they treating games
is because well they got their apple
so we know what's going on here i will
say this to king which is
absolutely hilarious the brazenness of
this damn fortnight
the audacity of this damn game that will
not go away like attic said
they had they are the most strong-arming
dudes i have ever seen
they locate hustle pubg out of their
engine store
made it better and then came out there
then
they went out there to sony accidentally
leaked cross-play
all of a sudden oh now they put this
thing yo sony what's up yo your fans
they saying
you know what i'm saying trying to act
like they are so ruthless
you got to consider that like you got it
they made sony
go away from one of the most traditional
things in console gaming
and so he's like look this is how we do
things in episodes oh that's cute that's
cute
that's not working it's getting better
did they say your pc dudes that's cute
you like steam
you not getting your game it's over here
on our store
and so what lay down or get down you're
not playing borderlands until you play
it over here so open up another launcher
and then the state people was like well
you know you only have fortnight we
don't care about florida
oh we only have fortnight okay this game
is so out of control like they are
weaponizing a game to get kids to get
angry
at like how atrocious like they are
nice i love one day i love it so much
it is absolutely genius
bro like they are literally like that
they know
a a developer came out with their own
game blew up so
big that they're in court right now and
they're trying to strong-arm
two of the biggest software companies in
the world
like somebody they have a deal with
already god
damn that's what i'm saying they signed
that deal already saying you can't do
this
then they gonna put the micro
transaction in knowing they gonna get
banned
they hadn't lost the video
they waited for that second of weakness
that argument with microsoft and they
saw they said what they got
and you know king king do you want to
know the craziest thing about this king
they about to make both of these
companies fold let's see
if they pull this off and it's not
it's not even in court you know why
they're going to make them fold because
people keep saying oh you know apple
don't need
fortnite money don't need for money but
those investors want that fortnite you
know
you know how to make them fold right
because chances are it's going to be
very difficult to prove
that these two platforms are monopolies
right it's going to be difficult because
it's their own platform and you're not
being forced to play on that valley
you can't attack so what i did start
seeing was a lot of devs coming out
talking about
how that 30 particularly on on the apple
store affects them negatively
there's a dev that says look we've paid
more to to apple for being on the app
store than we've made
back in our game for four years so it's
like if you have if
if they can get those devs to talk about
how that 30 is killing them and there's
no reason for it dude
the amount of all right the amount of
apps and games whatever on the app store
is so high that the
basically their return on investment for
that 30 they're getting
is really like a 300 to 400 percent win
for them
right like it's ridiculous the amount of
money they're making on each never i
mean just
just look at it from youtube perspective
they take 30 of all super chats from
every youtube channel
30 of all ad revenue and they take it
from everything that's
really what this is about yeah and
that's what that's what this is about
right because
from the beginning epic was like now
we're only taking 12. we're only taking
12 and we're still killing it we're
making all this money
why can't they do the same and it's it's
just about that
it's about shaming them into getting
into getting
getting to that
i don't know that they ever able to
prove that these guys are monopolies but
if they
do if they are able to bring in enough
people to be like yeah me too i feel
this way me too i feel this way
the pressure is gonna be enough like
when he did that to sony and made sony
bender need for cross play
sony turned around and gave them 120
that was a direct result of that
no if somebody do me wrong i'm not
bringing them no bread but
he's got a point there man no but he's
so
legit what they thought oh got a better
point though
has said that what's interesting is what
they're doing
is attacking the world garden right
that is technically sony's model
sony's whole model is to play best here
what hulk said was very interesting is
that they wonder
if sony knew about this prior to them
investing that money to now go again
because if they
win this case that is a threat against
all
platforms having exclusives that they
could come in and you can do what you
want
on a platform this opens up another
can of worms and homemade a good point
it's very interesting to see because
remember sony just invested in this
that's the logo
this loki is it this is a trojan horse
that they're trying to fit into the big
system
it's just we laugh is it it's just
you this is another multi-billion dollar
company who wants nothing more than to
take your money
acting like they're messiah like they're
virtuous
like they're sacrificing themselves for
you yeah
is just like it feels like every time
they accomplish something like making
people
uh cave make uh you know uh
trying to compete with steam steam steam
claps back they buy like eight
exclusives like
it seems like the more they do the
cockier they get bro they brazen
we got shroom kingdom with the two
dollar super chat fortnite pulled a push
of tea t
right there it's stupid um there we have
jonathan b with the five dollar super
chat the other layer to this is that
apple has an
active anti-trust case with the european
union right now
on your homie knowing
[Laughter]
that's the thing no one feel bad for
none of these companies whoever wins
i'm just saying we sit back get popcorn
and watch the show
it's absolutely hilarious
yeah it really is like godzilla king
kong and mothra
they're one of them talking about they
for the people you know
out of here anyway look i'm sorry what
do you say
i was like place your bets who you got
yeah who you got man let's just see what
happens
my money's with fortnight like my wife i
just
messy yo this is scary if they win bro
tim sweeney right now is 3-0 he's a
knockout
yo this is scary if they i don't know if
we want
whenever he put his sights on something
people were like
we gotta
they're all in the courtyard they see
tim come up and they're like he's got
his sniper who is that
yeah and then we didn't even mention how
he attacked remember he attacked uwp
yeah
and then and then a year later we get
game practices
out of control game and tell us if we
chat
with all the anti-christ fight who wins
that's
it's one of the things right now we're
gonna do the poll we gotta get out of
here this is a funny topic man
i didn't think that was gonna go down
it's a lot longer than i thought yeah
this topic was lit that's how it looked
do i have people with the recently
announced delay of halo infinite
what do you think microsoft should do to
help alleviate the loss of the title
during the series x launch
choices are a delay halo infinite was
the right call
launch the series x as is it will still
sell to the masses b sign a big
third party exclusive to game pass for
the series x launch
c buy wb games in bungie
give the bass hope or d
i don't care if i see craig again in
delayed halo infinite
throw 343 straight in the bushes
[Applause]
that is the cash please rock the boat
when it goes up shout out to
lord big cloud david man rocking with us
all the way through with a little
technical difficulty but he's still
rocking us all the way man absolute
pleasure to finally have you in the room
brother long overdue
where can you find people find you what
you got going on sir well first of all
thank you all for having me this was uh
fun thank you guys so much this is great
i appreciate you guys david that's my
brother you already know
going back it's good to see you guys go
from 300. i know you guys are back at
300 subs
now i'm happy for all of you it's it's
always a pleasure to talk to you even
off here we talk
you know we are playing destiny so it's
a pleasure man thank you so much for the
effort
shout out to everybody i know i see some
people from rgt in here so definitely
fun salute to you guys please everybody
thank you
um you guys can find me at big cloud
gaming on youtube and of course twitter
big cloud gaming man
play your games man enjoy yourselves man
everybody get into a new gin
a lot of funny stuff is ahead of us you
already know that
it's a big cloud man one of the good
guys in the community like i said
factual information plays keeps it fair
has his preference by the end of the day
good people and uh we all respect you
man we love your journey shout out to
the 7k bro like that was
i was super proud to see that man i see
you moving and um yeah man like like i
said
you know you don't want me to bring you
back so are you worried about that yeah
we definitely had to do that together
no it was funny we were playing destiny
i was playing ghosts and i was just like
this might just hit me up there
you hit 7k it was like what yeah
[ __ ] my reaction because i don't i don't
go i don't chase the subs i literally i
just i
go with the passion it's all passionate
i love what i do
i love the amount that i get to
associate with you know it's kind of
it's incredible that i've uh this far i
mean when i when i first hit 100
i didn't think i was 1k
i didn't think i was getting here i am
getting close to 10. so it's just
keep it going brother we see it in the
production value on fire man salute keep
it going man
that's what's up and uh of course you
already know lord
addict out here wanting the world to
burn wasn't pulling for epic games
going for 343 all savagery today we we
might have to change the attic world
thing with the world behind and have it
on fire
definitely want to appreciate uh you
know bit for coming on
here is his twitter info definitely go
follow him on twitter
uh another place you can find me is in
the victory circle on fall guys when
he's playing
so you know i definitely uh you know
first off i want to say
is that while the people that you know
we're i'm gonna have to reach out to
slo-mo
and uh the other person whenever you get
it just hit me up in the chat
in the comment section we'll definitely
get that out to you uh thanks for
everyone coming by definitely hit that
like button if you guys don't mind and
until next week i will see you next week
yes sir
lord son when everybody thought the
smoke was coming from you it came
elsewhere
what's going on sir how could a five
people find you it was kind of a smoke
bomb
it wasn't spoke from anyone surprising
for me so i you know i apologize to
anybody in the chat that wanted it you
know about
what can i do this is one of the very
few times we always like we gonna give
them smoke equally today
but yeah big shout out to big cloud like
cox said man i didn't realize how much
we had in common i would
much love to anybody who who puts on
that singlet
and and does your facebook yeah you know
those every single match was always
deemed as the six worst minutes of your
life
because they are really like your heart
you're pumping you got people watching
you don't know if you're gonna screw up
and it takes a special breed to do that
man so big shout out to you man
and and must love you everybody my first
time on varsity
yeah that was my first time ever on
varsity and we went to state
yeah i mean listen the first time i went
out there i was like i'm a baseball guy
so it was a sport that i did in the
winter
trying to yeah you know as kind of
preparing me and i've never been in such
good shape going into baseball season as
my first time
wrestling for sure it's a different type
of grind i mean you literally have to be
at the the peak i mean you think
football stuff but really football is
mostly
in the way it has i don't think nothing
for football players you know
knows who played football wrestling it
was just so much
more technical it's more aspect just
oh man you know what you can find me
working that's what i'm gonna do
[Music]
with the earth-shattering news today
just shocked each other chat was it oh
we got
quiet everything i've never seen
like the world stopped in the realm
everybody on the panel the whole chat
put ear emojis
everybody would i it was cr cake with
the fire today man
what's going on how i feel about phil
well first and foremost
uh i better needed a guest yes i'm in a
big cloud
um it did today was a really good day
because i already knew you was coming on
right so
this is my guy or whatever you know hit
the 7k you know
he moving and
when he was doing his top five i've
never
had 20 pounds worrying about somebody
else's
picks like so that lets you know how
much this dude
he he's he's my guy and i was sitting
there thinking because you you believe
that you know somebody's like gaming
habits right and i'm like if dino crisis
and resident evil
is both my knees
i'm gonna lose them i'm gonna lose them
but then you know i lost one knee so i'm
good
um also you know we were talking statues
and stuff in the background
so you know he's he's one hell of a dude
and and
definitely one of the most level-headed
dudes out here you know he's not with
that toxic nature
so if you do follow him and uh
if you don't follow him you need to
start following
him if you're an xbox dude listen he's
going to call it down the line of course
he plays
up on on sony's side but he's
real about it you know so there's no
capping for them but
it's just real stuff um once you got the
coast sign from boone i know it was lit
let me tell you yeah
game game i already know that's the home
uh
cloud if you ain't gonna see it go see
it
[Music]
um it was it was a good show this week
yeah
you really liked it for other reasons
solstice is going on these dudes
out here with the solstice and they
telling you how to uh get to
your gears attack you know if it's the
first time you're doing the solstice
definitely go check that out um also go
to lords of gaming.net
um right there say it again say it again
we got to do
today because they have something of
epic proportions there
if you guys don't know about this
fantastic game called skyward sword from
and read this article because it's an
epic
epic even the the man himself dan bushko
oh man of play nyc and play crafting
is definitely behind this one right here
so please i want you guys to go
one person that's the greatest nonsense
listen make sure that you hit a bunch of
likes on it
and make sure you leave comments and let
them know this is the best written
article of the year because
uh i'll write it all right it's the
undead on this one yeah
this is a beautiful thing and that did
his work and i'm gonna go read it and
i'm gonna read it again and i'm going to
recommend
it again for everybody else to read it
definitely go check it out this
fantastic game no doubt shout out
to get that david that the entire team
salute
but uh we got two super chats on the way
out yeah we got viper xc with the two
dollars to chat great show guys everyone
hit that like button yeah we have 156
now come on guys
let's get that up you got victor
allisteen with the five dollar super
chat great show guys i do hope microsoft
acquires wb interactive and possibly
bungie to solidify the base
no doubt listen that's rallying the
troops right there that's the
that's the tylenol moment for me but
anyway yeah man look you already know
what it is man again salute to my
brother big cloud
good to have him in the realm finally
long overdue we will be back you know
what i'm saying you know already know
how we do with that
and again you know salute for y'all for
rocco that's a little technical thing
youtube i don't know what was going on
with that
addict leo support my bro attic man he's
killing these videos and uh i really
love the production value he's been
stepping it up gaming attic channel
has been on fire he's been doing a lot
and he's doing a lot with the community
as well we got a lot of cool stuff
planned
so check that out as well and then of
course king ko asks you already know
what time it is if you're not on it get
on that youtube playlist
get on that lords of gaming.net if you
want the dimensions the statues all that
information and
he's going to give you a synopsis and
the history of the character so even if
you don't know what's going on are you
you can find out what's up uh viper
let me get his whole name real quick
that's the person that won that thing
uh viper xt if you have a twitter hit me
up
uh like tweet me you do something i got
to get you your stuff and i got to get
slow-mo history
yo you write about
craving i see him i see him coming that
would be crazy that would be crazy
but that's all i got me look everybody
enjoy your sunday we will be back next
week we'll let you know what's up and
we're out of here thanks for rocking
peace hi i'm lord king david of iron
lords podcast
and we're bringing to you an exciting
new giveaway
this giveaway is like none other we'll
be giving away
a xbox series x that's right
you heard me right the brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able to be
part of that giveaway there's two ways
to get your name thrown in the hat
for the raffle one become a member
of the realm that's hit that join button
hit that joy button you hit that join
button down at the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat daddy
fat stacks a member
and lord of the realm a
very generous person that's in our
community
and this community is beautiful
so remember you can have one entry
by hitting that join button and becoming
a member of the realm
and also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat
two times so please
like follow and subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
as to who did that for you sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure that you will enjoy